Elon Musk is now the largest stakeholder
in Twitter he bought 9.2 percent which
is uh just about three billion dollars
worth of the company and I don't know if
it means he can do anything but he was
just talking about on Twitter about free
speech he's on Twitter talk about the
importance of free speech everybody was
like yo start up a company and Mike
cernovich was like buy Twitter and then
Elon Musk was like I'll buy a lot a lot
of people are saying Donald Trump should
buy a steak in Twitter but three billion
dollars I think that's Trump's actual
net worth maybe a little bit less so he
couldn't buy 10 but he could buy maybe
one if he wanted to sink you know a
couple hundred million into it perhaps
but this is big maybe maybe Free Speech
will be returning to the platform aside
from that we got a big story in Black
lives matter apparently they secretly
purchased a I think it was a six million
dollar mansion so they could film
YouTube videos or something like that
and uh man the more we uncover about how
they were I don't know misusing funds
the crazier things get so we'll talk
about all that we got some crazy stories
Georgia has their own version of the
parental rights and education bill of
course the left is calling it The don't
say gay bill but this one's a little
different I'm surprised they haven't
already come out and started you know
screaming about this one we also have
got now I believe if if uh there's 25
states that are constitutional carry if
Florida moves forward with their special
legislative session we could have 26
States constitutional carry uh let's
talk about all this stuff and a whole
bunch of other stuff I suppose joining
us to discuss these issues is Amber
hey so glad to be here who are you shall
I introduce myself yes great
well yeah so I'm the Washington editor
for The Spectator oldest magazine in the
world we started our US edition about
three four years ago now and uh as of a
month ago I was a radio co-host but I
think we'll get into the scenario there
later on I got fired for uh
for talking about Kamala Harris
everyone's favorite vice president yeah
uh and then I'm also a senior fellow at
the steamboat Institute so you made um
you made a joke I did make a joke never
a good idea on Twitter apparently
they were looking for something
they uh yeah you made it you made an
offensive joke about Kamala Harris I did
yeah and used an old slogan that
apparently no one knows anymore I'm sure
everyone's like I I'm trying to tread
carefully over you know so we can save
some of the story but I'm sure
everyone's like whoa what did she say
was it really they're like oh my God she
said something really racist didn't she
no considering this the the era that
we're in it was like totally not racist
yeah and you know what's funny is
looking back on it I was at a trivia
night with my friends when I sent the
tweet that got me fired and I remember
going around the table
asking about the initial tweet that I
was going to send if it was safe and
everyone was like ah like it's a little
edgy maybe you should dial it down a
little bit so this was actually the
paired down version of the tweet and
that still was too far they're saying
you're even more racist than they
accused you of right so I'm now digging
myself even deeper into the racism hole
well we'll definitely talk about uh why
you got fired right this is so so stupid
I feel like there's a lot of things I
can't that I won't say on Twitter that
I'm like I have to save this for when I
can speak it with my mouth because it's
the tone if you don't have the tone to
preserve this the statement they just
look for the words and then they they
give that words a bad word you can't do
that one uh I I especially talking about
bodily functions that's a big thing I
try to say for the show I don't want to
put it in texture yeah
what's up yeah hey look here I'm also
here in the corner thank you guys very
much for tuning in I'm excited for this
evening I always love my ladies and I
want to hear why she got fired Sheamus
is not here tonight she ditched us yeah
he ditched us he was like I'm gonna hang
out with my family we were like dude wow
yeah you think your family is more
important than The World Is This Love or
something yeah get out of here no uh but
yeah no Sheamus tonight know anybody
else but uh let's let's jump into it
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to support our work as a member you'll
get access to exclusive episodes of the
Tim castero podcast Monday through
Thursday 8 P.M we will have an uh one of
these episodes up tonight for you again
at I say 8 P.M 11 p.m yeah okay not 8
p.m at 11 p.m after the show so make
sure you sign up and as a member you're
keeping our journalists employed because
this is how they get paid basically you
guys sign up and then they do work
writing stories and uh we we greatly
appreciate it but don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel right now on YouTube Share the
show in any way possible if you really
want to help us out we have have no paid
marketing for the show it's all organic
growth so we do rely on people just to
be like hey I like the show and share it
it really does help let's jump into this
first story and talk about the the world
is changing so quickly yep Elon Musk
acquires 9.2 stake in Twitter the
world's richest man is now the social
media Giant's largest shareholder my
understanding is that he's also the
largest uh he has the largest vote he's
bigger than uh Vanguard I think whatever
whatever yeah is it BlackRock yeah I
thought maybe yeah
they uh timbus.com writes on Monday a
filing with the Securities and Exchange
Commission revealed that Elon Musk has
acquired a 9.2 stake in the social media
giant the move by musk reportedly the
world's richest man comes just weeks
after he started criticizing the
platform for its violations of free
speech his criticism was followed by a
rumor that he might create a new
competing platform similar to Twitter
the SEC filing shows that he purchased
roughly 73.4 million shares in the
company making him the largest
shareholder on Twitter according
according to the financial times Jack
founder only holds 2.25 percent stake in
Twitter musk has not spoken publicly
about the acquisition previously
indicated he wanted to see dramatic
changes on Twitter of course he has a
bunch of tweets it says I'm giving
serious thought to this he was tweeting
out free speech saying what should be
done
I don't know if he can do anything he
conducted a poll on Twitter asking his
followers I think Twitter regular
rigorously adheres to the principles of
free speech he noted that the
consequence of the online poll would be
significant seventy percent of the 2
million Twitter respondents said no
that's crazy the first few months of new
Twitter CEO parag agrawal's tenure
validated some concerns his leadership
would reduce free expression since
Agarwal took the position at Twitter of
the site permaband one of the accounts
of Congressman Marjory Taylor green for
allegedly violing its covid-19
misinformation policy and then of course
she she heavily criticized them recently
former New York Times Reporter Alex
Berenson sued Twitter over his band
August 2020 and uh then we also have an
editor's note full correction initial
reporting said 9.7 there were a few a
few outlets at 9.7 it was 9.2 the big
question ladies and gentlemen does this
matter I feel very tired and bored by
these conversations about Twitter and
you know I mean you got fired over
Twitter so maybe it matters no maybe it
doesn't matter well I mean Twitter
didn't fire me so I mean technically it
doesn't matter but
I don't know I just I we keep hearing
these stories coming out about how like
so and so starting a new social media
company and this is finally going to
change things and I just feel always
disappointed like I'm super black pilled
about just the general idea of social
media
um not just because of censorship
reasons but because of the effect that
it's having on our you know societal
interactions and the way kids are raised
and all of these different things social
media addiction
I don't even I don't know how much power
this actually gives Elon Musk
um I've seen people smarter than I say
that quite a lot apparently I I hope
that it changes I guess I'm just
generally pessimistic about the state of
social media in general and I don't even
know if Twitter is really worth saving
at this point because you you have to
change not just the policies in terms of
you know the vaccine misinformation you
weren't allowed to say for a while there
that if you had the vaccine that you
could still get covered you could still
spread covet and really stupid things
like that but there's also a lot of
algorithmic issues in terms of how they
decide what content gets promoted what
content gets Shadow banned and things
like that so there's there's so many
things that need to change across the
board to make this a better platform and
I mean hopefully Elon Musk is the guy to
help do it but again I I don't have high
hopes for anything regarding Twitter
Facebook Instagram whatever some people
are saying that he does get substantial
voting power and he could move to make
himself a board member and then as a
board member he can make some real
changes he's charismatic too yeah you
need to be on the board one maybe be on
the board so he Vanguard owns 8.39 at
least this is from CNN so he is the
largest stakeholder now the thing is so
you want to talk about changing the
terms of service to make it a free
speech Network you could base it out of
like Connecticut and then you have to
adhere to to state law uh corporate law
but then the thing is the NSA can come
in and say hey we don't like that guy
shut his account down and you're not
allowed to tell anyone here's a gag
order and then they have to because they
have the data if you don't know who the
people are and you don't have their data
you can't the CIA can't come and take it
from you you see an NSA interchangeably
it's crazy
um I think really honestly forcing
companies to change their terms of
service is a big ask and it feels very
fascist to use political force to make a
private company do something like that I
think that free speech on the Internet
is a different kind of free speech and
that it's more about the code because if
it's spying on you and you don't know
you're not really free if you're if
you're constantly being watched and sold
out behind or or possibly a better uh
question is if the algorithms are hidden
and people are being shadow band and
silenced without you knowing that you're
not in a fair system yeah you should
know the NSA came and they shut that
they took that data they shut that guy
down that you should always know that
stuff because you see it happen on the
network yeah and a lot of times Twitter
doesn't even tell people why they're
being banned I mean they say sometimes
you're being removed for this tweet and
you have to delete it otherwise you're
not allowed you have a suspension but
sometimes they don't really tell people
and then when inevitably usually
conservative in an independent media go
up in arms about what's going on they
say oh it was just a mistake you know
somebody in inaccurately flagged this
tweet for violating terms of service and
so they're really not transparent about
even when people are violating things
what specific policy they're violating
or which tweet was the violation
sometimes they'll say that somebody was
getting around a previous ban by
creating new accounts or that their
email address has multiple accounts
registered to it and it all just seems
like they're playing these games to try
to get around actually enforcing their
policies fairly across the board a good
point I think that if someone gets
banned if account gets banned that the
the ban reason should be on the
blockchain for them for reference
yeah but then what if they put bunk
info on the blockchain and we'll say you
should be able to appeal it and then the
appeal should be on the blockchain to be
able to watch the process if it was
that's true because then you can see
they lied because we check out the
stories it's from a year ago Twitter
bans James O'Keefe yeah of project
advertis over fake account policy in
suggesting that he was operating
multiple accounts in an unsanctioned way
O'Keefe has already announced that he
will sue the company for defamation and
that's legit because James was like I
did not write multiple accounts and when
you asked Twitter about this because
I've done this I reached out to them
about this exact issue and I have a
press contact at Twitter that like
claims to be from conservative world so
they're always like oh well we'll put
you the conservative media journalist to
reach out to this person because they
can be trusted because they used to work
for a Republican or whatever it's all Bs
but I reach out to them about these
types of issues all the time of them
claiming that people got banned for
these account violations and when you
ask for evidence of it what they tell
you is oh well it's a Personnel issue or
it's a company policy issue and we can't
talk anymore about it and even with
James himself and other people who have
had this happen to them they won't talk
about it with them either so how are you
supposed to get any accountability when
they keep doing this to people I I
wonder where James is with this lawsuit
because I mean they banned him and then
outright made a statement about
something he did that he didn't do yeah
with no evidence and so he can easily
just say to a judge like your honor I
didn't operate multiple accounts they
claimed I did that's defamation the
judges I I have to imagine he's going to
be like okay let's let's go to Discovery
and easily determine whether or not he
was or wasn't
yeah I think that's exactly right the
other problem with Twitter in particular
is that they have this sort of whoa
corporate structure where they're hiring
these kids who are on college campuses
like protesting against speakers and
shutting people down those are the
people that are getting hired at the big
tech companies and those are the ones
that are actually in charge of enforcing
the terms of service so you already have
you have the biased algorithms and then
you have an extra layer of bias with the
people who are in charge of actually
enforcing the policies and so it's
really no wonder that things like this
happen so if elon's going to get in here
he has to basically go through the
entire payroll of Twitter and try to
root out some of these people who are
acting as activists as opposed to people
who are trying to fairly enforce terms
of service so the reason why blockchain
Administration would be good because if
you have a bunch of miscalculations of
bands that weren't right you'd be like
oh it was on December 23rd who was
admitting on December 23rd at 4 pm it's
all accountable I you may want these
corporations may want to hide that from
the public because they want to protect
their employees and I get that to a
point but also the public when it's in
the Commons the public deserves I
believe the control of the system and
knowing who's screwing with the system
this is the commons I think Elon also
sees this as the commons I'm I was uh
listening to something about Tick Tock
and some some young tic-tocker was like
oh yeah Twitter's dumb it's just for
like politics no one cares and I think
that's a fair assessment too many of us
are on Twitter because it's a political
social network that's what it is it's
politics and journalism everything else
is like what's the point you're going to
go there and follow you know Brad Pitt
for whatever reason or whatever
celebrate not really you're not and
that's why even the New York Times gets
no interaction on any of their tweets
the real point of Twitter is to go on
and be mean to people and emotionally
destroy them well the second reason is
to talk about news politics and social
you can also message people directly
which is pretty cool like I sent Jordan
a message yesterday I've never met him
before but Peterson yeah Peterson oh
yeah Jordan Peterson disagree with your
third of your 40 second rules dude your
third one talks about always being
honest sometimes laws are bad and you
can't be honest about it
anyway we'll talk about that later but
yeah I wonder if Twitter just becomes
Irrelevant in 10 years it very well
could I mean I've there's always this
phrase that people throw out right
Twitter's not real life and it's 100
true I mean I'm like a Twitter obsessed
fool and I go out and I talk to my
friends or my family back home about
this stupid tweet I saw and they have no
idea what I'm talking about or some
manufactured controversy that left-wing
activists on Twitter are all up in arms
about and again nobody who even people
who like consume Fox News or CNN
incessantly don't really know what's
going on on Twitter unless they are
actively on there for multiple hours a
day but this but Twitter does have a
huge impact on policy it does so it's
it's almost like the Forefront of
thought in a lot of ways when it comes
to politics and journalism you'll get
someone like uh David Hogg had a tweet
which is really important it is because
seeing his internal monologue his inner
monologue is important to understand
that you shouldn't listen to his advice
on anything right when he tweeted you
need what do you say you need a license
to kill deer why don't you need a
license to kill humans yeah as if to
imply you're allowed to or like you
could go to the government be like I
would like to kill people like well
here's your license to Kill sir like you
can't kill people like they're they're
only you know extenuating circumstances
you're defending yourself or you're in
war or something but normally these
activists and high profile profile
individuals would go through some
several filters before that message
would actually get out not because of
Twitter people are just thinking things
and then tweeting it right you know I
take advantage of that and just tweet
things that I know are intentionally
ridiculous yeah and then it's weird you
know you don't think works for the left
is that most of most of the leftists
know my tweets tend to be nonsense but
they know their followers don't so
they're like I can retweet this guy and
even though I know it's sarcasm or
something or silliness or trolling but
everyone else take it seriously but
anyway I digress the point is
AOC talks about the green New Deal you
know these these politicians talk about
policy positions and plans and they
manifest on Twitter antifa organizes
rallies on Twitter so sure you can be
one of these older guys on Fox News
having no idea what's going on and then
one day you you look out your window
there's a guy throwing a Molotov
cocktail you know at your building and
you're like why is that happening well
look at Twitter they were talking about
it for the past three days there was a
shift in I don't know if it's 2013 2012.
all of a sudden CNN started getting
screenshots of tweets like like I was
from the pre-internet age before social
media and then I would make a bunch of
YouTube videos then all of a sudden it
was like it's a big deal to get
mentioned on TV then all of a sudden the
news is no longer on CNN the news is on
Twitter CNN's referencing Twitter tweets
tweets they're referencing tweets on CNN
yeah and it's not the problem is is
Twitter only has as much value and power
as we assign to it and media companies
in particular have assigned a lot of
value to what people say on Twitter
whether negative or positive they will
pull up random accounts with like 30
followers and be screenshotting their
tweets and putting them on a prime time
cable news program as if this is like a
serious person with real thoughts that
matter in the Public Square and I mean
it's gotten to this point now where I
think you're right that Twitter is
setting a lot of policy I mean I would
love to know for example where like the
don't say gay moniker came from I
wouldn't be surprised if that came from
some left-wing Twitter account some like
12 year old yeah that's the funniest
thing about CNN putting tweets on TV is
that it's probably some 12 year old kid
who you know tweeted having no idea this
is actually a really important point on
Twitter you you don't know you're
arguing arguing with a 14 year old the
dude who got uh Harry's Razors to to
dump daily wire claims to have been High
School I wouldn't doubt it and so just
think about how insane that is that some
high school kid desperate for attention
or to like have an impact because it's
you know it's trolling right you want
you want to feel your pressure or your
presence on the world sees a story takes
their account and it'll be called like
you know bro dude 54 and they tweet I
think Joe Biden is the greatest
president Donald Trump was bad because
you know he was racist and then CNN's
like here's a tweet from someone who
matters and it's like it's just some 12
year old kid who has no idea what he's
talking about I knew a dude who who gave
a fake interview to a local there's a
plane crash Chicago and this dude ran
there afterwards and then told the
journalist that he had seen it he's like
oh yeah he's like I was here when it
happened and they said what happened and
he just made a story up because he
wanted to be on TV now he was an adult
at the time but imagine a 12 year old
they'd be like I don't know you know
where your parents so you can be 12. go
on Twitter
say Joe Biden's economic plan is
destabilizing this country and then a
network will be alike we should put that
tweet up and show people when you're
getting your opinions from a rant from A
random assortment it could be children
have no idea what they're talking about
and that's probably true a lot for the
left because the left tends the
Democrats tend to have a lot more
younger people
so imagine just all of these
conservatives on Twitter arguing with
people and it's like a 56 year old guy
arguing with a 14 year old just just
don't do it don't argue not in text it's
it's never good and I have to remind
myself all the time if I send out a
particularly
not even edgy I don't really tweet edgy
things I don't think but if I tweet
something that gets a lot of Engagement
from people on the opposite side of the
political Spectrum I'm so guilty of
seeing some accounts say something like
really stupid and I'm like I have to
quote tweet them and dunk on them and
it's literally someone with an egg as
their profile picture and it's and
that's why like the addiction aspect of
it is so crazy to me because it really
does fire off like those receptors in
your brain that make you want to engage
constantly and scroll constantly and
even someone who is aware of it has that
impulse and imagine how bad that is for
people who don't really understand
what's happening so Elon Musk buys this
big steak in Twitter but I'm not
entirely convinced that it matters
because it's it's the cultural issues on
uh in our society outside of Twitter
matter more so in in your instance Amber
you got fired because you tweeted a joke
about Kamala Harris that was you made
fun of the way she dressed that's right
they called you racist on Twitter yeah
so uh basically what happened was a
month ago was the state of the union and
Kamala was wearing this horrific brown
suit which I like everybody agreed that
it was ugly right I don't think I'm the
only one that thought it was bad uh I
Saturday Night Live made fun of it and
there were people like photoshopping her
to look like a UPS employee
and so I decided to throw out this tweet
saying Kamala looks like a UPS employee
what can Brown do for you nothing good
apparently because obviously she's
ineffective at public policy and bad at
her job
well a few days later how this all
actually shook out was
I don't know if you guys remember this
there were a bunch of protests at the
University of North Texas because the
young conservatives Club on campus had
decided to invite this guy named Jeff
younger and Jeff younger is a dad whose
son was taken away from him because the
Mom was convinced that the son was
actually a daughter and wanted to
transition him medically and the dad was
not about it so young conservatives for
Texas had this guy come to campus and of
course the sjws on campus freaked out
had these crazy protests and I got
involved in this debate on Twitter again
never a good idea but here we are
um in the replies to Matt Walsh actually
and there's this freelance reporter for
The Daily Beast Yahoo news uh Rolling
Stone I think named Stephen Monticelli
and I point to him as like the root
cause of all of this he
took a screenshot of the Kamala tweet
because he was mad at me for saying you
can't chemically castrate kids
and
sent it to all of his followers and his
followers decided that they were going
to start emailing my employers to say
that I was a racist and needed to be
fired and what where where were you
working so I was with the spectator wmal
which was a radio station based in DC
it's like the conservative talk radio
station in DC and that I have a
fellowship with the steamboat Institute
The Spectator wmal wmal and it's a part
of cumulus media that's like the
corporation that owns a bunch of radio
stations so similar to their trash
they're trash they're operated by a
bunch of liberals who don't care about
anything outside of radio they make all
their money from conservative radio but
they don't actually believe in anything
that their hosts are saying on air is
this long and short of it the spectator
literally laughed at these emails they
were getting because they thought they
were so ridiculous wmal a week later
calls me after I host the show on a
Wednesday morning
and tells me that my tweet was racist
that it violated their social media
policy and that they were terminating me
effective immediately no severance
nothing I was done I wasn't going back
on the show the next day they didn't
inform anybody else on the show that I
was hosting so they were like Sol they
didn't even have a host for the next
morning they had to have somebody else
fill in
uh they didn't tell the wmal program
director it was a vice president and the
VP of HR I have the termination letter
and everything that confirms everything
that I'm telling you guys people you
worked with didn't stand up for you and
be like I'm not going to do it
they tried I will say that there was a
lot of internal maneuvering over the
past month which is why I've waited so
long to go public with the story because
I wanted to see if cumulus and wmao
would do the right thing a lot of the
hosts they're on contracts so they can't
really just walk out uh without facing
pretty heavy Financial uh consequences
it's not understanding
I don't want to throw them under the bus
because they have been speaking out on
my behalf publicly since I've talked
about this this morning
but I understand your perspective
um I wish people were more willing to uh
just
stand up
consequences be damned there's so many
people on the left there that are are
willing to risk prison time burning down
police stations and doing the most
insane things and conservatives won't
even risk a contract violation it's like
oh no contract violation you're gonna
have to go into arbitration those
companies don't want to spend money on
lawyers you know so if you were like I'm
not going to do the show and they're
like well you're in breach of you'll be
in breach of contract and it's like okay
spend five dollars retaining your lawyer
because I I refuse to do a show one day
and let's see how much money got to
waste before you get me to agree a
monthly I'll tell you this I just it
just pisses me off they'd come to me and
they'd say you're in breach of contract
we're going to sue you I say okay I'm
gonna wait you out however long it takes
you to put your lawyers and retainer to
file and then you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna let you win then I'm gonna
make you sink 20 grand into legal fees
then I'll come back how's that sound or
you can just say we're not gonna fire
someone over a tweet people just aren't
willing to even put a little bit of
pressure on their company yeah and I
will say I was allowed to go on Dan
bongino's show today and Dan bongino's
show is nationally syndicated one of the
radio stations that hosts his program
from 12 to 3 P.M every day wmal
so I got to go on the radio station that
fired me and tell all of their listeners
exactly what the company did to me and
Dan bongino was actually kind enough to
offer me a bi-weekly segment on the show
as well so he's putting his money where
his mouth is I mean he also he's gotten
into it with cumulus before over their
vaccine mandate so this isn't the first
time like he he hates them rightfully
totally understandable if you have seen
their like internal and I can't go into
too much because of the confidentiality
agreement I don't think they'll sue me
but I would rather not risk it they have
a lot of stuff on their internal company
forums that is just horrendous I mean if
the listeners knew the things that they
were promoting internally whether it's
some of the trainings that they do or
some of the financial bonuses they offer
people for doing certain things they
would be absolutely horrified that they
are giving their listenership to this
company sounds like project Veritas
might be picking something up from there
yeah I I would love to see James O'Keefe
do a little digging on that
I'm not surprised that these
corporations don't care about anything
yeah um I'm also not surprised there are
a lot of people who are like well
there's nothing I can do about it
because you know I'm under contract and
I'm also not surprised that Dan bongino
was like I don't care let's do it
because Dan is doing a lot to push back
you know he's invested in Rumble they've
got something called parallel economy do
you guys know about this uh only by name
alternative uh financial transaction
service so cool you're you're they're
build you know I'm a big proponent of
supporter of and working towards
parallel systems right for a while I
talked about how it was it was dangerous
and this was this was years ago I was
like if they keep Banning people this
way if financial institutions keep doing
this you're going to make a parallel
economy you do not want that now we're
here and it's like okay if that's what
they wanted it's it's we're past it
you've got to do it so parallel economy
if you you could do a subscription
service and not have to worry about
being banned by someone tweet you know
tweeting oh but they're racist or
whatever this company is going to be
like you know we don't care and Dan
mangino I believe he's an investor I'm
not entirely sure but I know he's
involved so man at least we have people
like him doing stuff that's that's
something yeah I mean if I were a host
on that station still I would be
terrified about what could happen to me
because you can't do political
commentary if you can't make fun of a
politician's outfit like that is the
most basic of things that you should be
allowed to do how are you supposed to go
on the air and tell the listeners that
you're committed to truth if you work
for a company that censors you if you
get anywhere close to the edge which I
don't even think this was I to me this
is like one of the most clear-cut cases
of just dishonest bad faith cancel
culture [ __ ] but
that's that's how it is nowadays like
you can't say anything
um and you have to be so Anodyne and
boring
that it is literally destroying
political commentary I think people have
been too uh to play complacent with uh
corporate corporations they've gone too
far they're not people
yeah they need to be that whole system
needs to be shattered cultural man it's
it's beyond it's an aberration now it
needs to be changed how many uh ballpark
how many people you know worked directly
or indirectly with you with me on the
show uh maybe five if those five people
were like we're all sick today
they'd be like higher Amber back
apologize to her yeah instead they're
just like well I'm not gonna do anything
you know that's the thing that people
don't understand it's not even about you
know stepping on the toes and trying to
you know cause some pain to the company
who's playing BS it's just literally
being like Oh we must have all got sick
at the same time I mean we all work
together so it makes sense yeah we're
gonna be at what's up what's Our Sick
Sick uh how much time do we have two
weeks yeah oh I think we're gonna be
sick for a little while and they're
gonna be like okay okay okay we get it
because what what are they really mad
about you tweeted what can Brown do for
you the UPS slogan they don't care about
that
it's just they don't they are trying to
avoid reputational damage and they made
a huge miscalculation because they
thought that firing me was the easy
thing to do this would get the Bad
actors off of their back they'd stop
getting emails sent to corporate and
they could go and tell the CEO or
whoever see we took care of this problem
well they didn't what they thought was
going to happen was that I was going to
sit down and shut the hell up and not
tell anybody because I'd be so
embarrassed well the opposite is true
I'm pissed off I think it's horrible and
I'm going to drag them to the ends of
the Earth to destroy their reputation as
publicly and as loudly as I possibly can
and I'm going to get as many other
conservatives and independent thinkers
on my side to also try to destroy their
reputation because that's all I know how
to do at this point I wouldn't call it
destroying I would say be honest about
sure expose expose expose Ruth yes yeah
and that's what I've been committed to
my entire career so I I don't know know
like what they thought that I was or who
I was but that's not it corporate media
is such a joke
it's like you like you need your court
your media run through a filter of an
authoritarian Corporation hell no it's
individual yeah now people can go out
there with the camera and get it done
man you don't need these stupid
companies yeah this is why I think we're
particularly lucky with Tim cast and
that we have no external influences no
beneficiaries no investors
the only person that could ever be like
I'm the I'm the buck stops with me so
and and I'm kind of hot-headed and you
know people call me arrogant and all
that stuff if somebody got fired I
wouldn't be like hey like we don't we
don't want to step on any toes here
because you know their big company we
advertise I'm gonna be like uh let's
let's take the emails let's throw them
down to the table take pictures of them
post them on the Internet put our feet
up and crack a cigar and tell everybody
exactly what happened yeah I I feel the
exact same way and that was my instinct
as soon as this happened I talked to a
lot of people about it I I spent a month
letting people internally try to do what
they could do I explore some legal
options I was an at-wheel employee so
there's not a whole lot you can do in
that situation and their social media
policy let me see if I can bring it up
because this is kind of interesting I
think it's pretty obvious that this is a
cya policy and it exists so that they
can fire people for any reason
whatsoever it's usually why they have it
one thing I'll say too as you're pulling
it up this is what the right needs to
understand about uh activism when I work
for non-profits they would do
postcarding where these non-profit
organizations would hire people and have
them fill out postcards they would have
them go outside and ask people to just
sign their name to a postcard then they
would take thousands and put them all in
the mailbox and then one day a member of
Congress just like here as you go here
you go and they wheelbarrow in all the
postcards and just leave them in their
room and they're like wow look at all
these people who are who are angry you
know I better act this way or I better
react to this you get 50 people who send
emails to a Serial company and the
serial company is like oh no everybody
wants us to do something so lucky charms
better go woke and in this instance the
woke started sending emails to to wmal
right and then they say oh just fire
it'll make it all go away yeah because
they know or they're hoping that
conservatives won't email them
complaining that they fired someone over
a Twitter joke because
the left is just chaotic and and and out
for some kind of yeah I don't know the
crazy thing is 4chan had this reputation
for the longest time of you know don't
mess with 4chan they'll come after you
now I guess for whatever reason you
don't really hear a lot about that it's
it's the left who hasn't has has become
The Hornet's Nest remember remember it
was a Colbert talking about Anonymous
and he was talking about this company
called I think it was H what was it uh
what was it called hhb Gary was that
what it was I don't know no it was
something Federal I don't know maybe it
was HP but the uh Colbert was talking
about the security company that went
after Anonymous and he said that's like
saying you know they wanted to stick
their dick in a hornet's nest and then
kick it or something like that it used
to be 4chan and the libertarian and the
right that were the Hornets Nest to be
feared not to screw with now it's antifa
on the left because the corporations are
terrified of them and the right doesn't
do anything brigading is that what it's
called or get a bunch of people to go do
something I I kind of realized the power
of that 2007 I think Obama was running
for office I was like oh we can get this
guy elected let's all vote for Obama
everyone listening vote for Obama I
would just tell people vote for Obama
yeah and they did it and then I was like
we could all pull our money out of the
bank at the same moment on the same day
and I was like I think it might be is
that illegal to call for that no I don't
think so so like mad power and then I
started to get scared like oh if I did
that and crashed the economy that could
be very bad yeah our brigading is real
and there are a lot of
sort of more formal left-wing advocacy
organizations like sleeping Giants that
were formed on social media and do these
harassment campaigns Media Matters is
sort of Infamous for going after
people's advertisers they basically
managed to bully all of Tucker Carlson's
advertisers out of being on his show for
example
um because they just for them it's it's
not obviously not about oh we really
care about racism and sexism and
homophobia and all that they care about
just trying to shut up anybody who
disagrees with them politically that's
the real goal because they use these
things so dishonestly but I have the
social media policy here
so the only thing that I could think of
that this potentially violated
was employees must not use internet
venues in a manner that may cause public
to spread it to employee or to the
company so like I said it's a cya it's
if we if you do anything we don't like
whether on air off air we can fire you
under this policy and you that will be
considered firing for cause we don't owe
you any Severance you lose all of your
union benefits and you're screwed uh and
then they probably assume that people
will be scared by the confidential
confidentiality aspect of this handbook
and not talk about it uh but again that
wasn't going to happen but your Tweet
was so just not even I mean like what if
you called Kamala a disgusting Pig you
know
that's a good question he would have
been fine I think yeah I think I
probably would have been okay it's the
word Brown yeah do people have become
that sensitive to this Insanity yeah uh
that you're talking about colors like if
what can and if you use red they
wouldn't have done anything about it
it's the color brown black white the
shades black and white are very
sensitive words yellow is another one
you can't do that that's in okay you can
you just well that's why I use tone but
we can take a box of Lucky Charms oh the
camera's not oh no yes we can we can put
a box of Lucky Charms next to Sheamus or
Sheamus chose to do it and someone sent
it to him and everyone laughs and it's
funny that he's like you know I'm Irish
so there's leprechauns or whatever do
you guys think the corporation should
have the right to do that what they did
to you
oh yeah absolutely yes it's a cultural
problem
company companies should be able to uh
and for the most part fire people for
you know any reason I say for the most
part there's probably certain
circumstances where you know like
retaliation after you abuse someone
physically and things like that but I
don't know why you'd want to work there
so maybe we should just let companies
suffer with you know people if they if
they want to it's probably a longer
conversation there but uh the issue is
the culture yeah a company shouldn't
want to do that and and not only that if
a company says well you put up a mean
tweet about the you know the the brown
vice president so we're firing you and
then if the other five people were like
we quit
that that even even that among the
employees would prevent the the
corporations oh yeah you could build you
could build organization within the the
company's employees to resist this kind
of behavior but 20th century
corporations which is what they are
right now aren't equipped to handle 21st
Century Media because they're getting
bombarded through a central service with
all these 50 100 people sending emails
to this one guy or this small group of
people and they're overloading their uh
their like helpline I think what's
interesting in my case is the backlash
wasn't that big I mean I've had people
try to cancel me before and this was
relatively minor in comparison it was
like maybe 10 people sent an email I
would guess it wasn't this bombardment
that would really lead any honest like
real leader to say
this is too much like this girl's gotta
go she's causing us a huge headache and
when you have this policy that talks
about how you can't discredit the
company like in my from my perspective
again this is a huge miscalculation
because they are now being publicly
discredited 5 10 50 times more than they
would have otherwise because of this
decision to fire me you know exactly
that's good I I have to say this I
honestly don't care about Kamala
Harris's outfit being all brown it is
weird so I actually have some some I
have I have a I have other clothes this
may be shocking to many people but I
have a brown button up and then I have
you know like round t-shirts and one day
I was like let's see like what should I
wear when I go skate or go out and then
I looked at them both and I'm like man I
would totally look like I worked for UPS
if I wore that so you're a racist too
yeah the problem with Pamela is her her
jacket's the same color as the desk
that's a big mistake so it'd be like if
you had your shirt was the same color as
the wall behind you it would look crazy
it's not a great shade of brown in my
opinion but yeah it's like poop brown
yeah yeah like what was she thinking it
does look like the poop emoji yeah what
can Brown do for you well for Kamala
Harris her outfit that is like the UPS
color too yeah it is I mean people have
put the UPS logo on her jacket yeah it
was a meme and it was dead on dead on
well people just gotta
you know you know there needs to be
conservative activist organizations and
I hate saying the word conservative
because that's not even the issue just
not woke yeah there needs to be not well
not stupid yeah civil libertarian I
think is the is the is the right word
that encompasses conservatives and
moderates civil libertarian like there's
a there's a there's a tweet going around
from some dude and he's like cancel
culture has no place in America then
it's like the night I think Define else
posted this and the next the next tweet
is him saying Disney should be straight
and I'm like that's not cancel culture
not at all right people think that not
spending your money with a certain
business is cancer culture now like
that's the less new talking point is
that if you do anything inter like they
boycott people all the time right but
and then when conservatives do it
they're like no no you're doing the
cancel culture now you're doing the
cancel calls those are saying boycotts
and sanctions are not the same thing
cancel culture are when you're fired
from a job for saying something or
banned from Twitter that's a sanction
cancel culture is digging up messages
and taking them out of context taking
messages out of context it's when you
get someone fired or harassed for
something that is not genuine for the
most part saying Disney does awful
things so we shouldn't provide them with
any services and give them the boot is
just being like this is a bad company
who literally does things they don't
like that's the whole point of having a
free market capitalist system is that
you're supposed to be able to spend your
dollars where you want to and and be
able to make those sort of more moral
decisions about your finances and then
I'd also add that I think cancel culture
is when the punishment doesn't fit the
crime so if you're trying to get someone
fired for a tweet that is an unjust
consequence for something that they
supposedly did wrong well then what's my
question to you then do you think the
corporation should be able to fire
people like that like whenever they want
I mean if I signed an at-wheel contract
so they're within their right to do so I
spent a lot of time on social media and
thinking like should social media
companies have the ability to ban
whoever they want at any time and I
usually land on yeah because I think
ultimately what we're going to head
towards is near infinite amounts of
social media Network all working in
parallel with different terms of service
all the different networks a lot
different terms and all the code will be
similar so they'll all be interoperating
I just don't see that corporations at
the moment I don't know how to stop
these authoritarians from just
destroying someone's livelihood at will
did you guys see that story about uh I
think Lori Lightfoot is going to give
away was it 50 000 gas cards yeah yeah
and I was thinking about that's kind of
funny like what do you call it when it's
communism but it's not for everyone it's
only for a randomly selected Lottery and
I was like is that Demar communism yeah
something like that like like only 10
percent get to bask in the comments
randomism Welcome to our new government
well well Denver I hope you roll a one
Dem Marquis is random government people
are randomly chosen to also as like
Denmark communism yeah but anyway I
bring this up because I'm thinking like
you know what we should do for for
timcast is just whenever there's like
layoffs we'll just have uh everyone will
have to hold a potato
and then whoever's holding the potato
when the buzzer goes off is fired and so
everyone will constantly be throwing it
but like if you throw it and no one
catches it it's it's yours and we got
cameras we'll know so you gotta get
someone else to catch it yeah and then
everyone will be throwing it to each
other and then you never know and then
we'll just like never put the buzz
around for like a week so everyone's
just walking around throwing a potato
around that's that's nice Pockets
the whole time all right let's talk
about this uh uh speaking of cancer
culture let's talk about people who
should be canceled from The Daily Mail
black lives matter secretly used six
million dollars in donations to buy
luxurious 6 500 square foot mansion with
seven bedrooms and parking for 20 cars
in Southern California in 2020 where the
leaders have filmed YouTube videos
absolutely amazing emails show The Firm
wanted to keep the purchase a secret
despite filming a video on The house's
Patty homes patio in May the news comes
the foundation faces Federal scrutiny
for alleged misuse of donation funds and
comes in the heels of criticism of
co-founder Patrice Cole colors colors 38
came under Fire last year for a slew of
high profile property purchases she
resigned after facing backlash from
critics and supporters and uh I'm
willing to bet that if you go to any
Democrat activist or left-wing person
and say hey this is bad right they'll go
well I mean it you know it's but so what
I mean well this is not black lives
matter and it's just you can point out
the money's missing that their address
isn't real that they bought Mansions
this lady's got multiple homes and
they'll still just be like but but but
but
yeah you see I I don't I don't I don't
know if there's an equivalent is there
an equivalent to like BLM on the right
not really no nowhere for lives matter
is an aberration on society and it's
very unique it's like a communist uh
aberration yeah there's a bold statement
intentionally seated I mean whether or
not they the Communists wanted to create
it I don't think so but it's it's very
uh it's been infiltrated
well and the person who's done a lot of
good reporting on this because I just
want to give him a shout out I used to
work with him Andrew Kerr he's at I
believe the Washington examiner now and
he was the one who broke this story
about last year black lives matter has
this like 60 million dollar War chest
essentially and he found out that there
was no one in charge of it for eight
months
like nobody knew where this money was
what they were doing with it who
actually had access to it and then
Patrice callers who had resigned over
buying all of these homes in the
backlash that accompanied that claimed
that there were two other people who
were supposed to be in charge of blm's
finances and then they found out that
those two people had never even
officially taken over that position and
they still haven't provided any answers
they've tried to delay the reporting of
uh their previous fiscal year finances
and just across the board there's all
this corruption that's going on in BLM
and like to me this is just the latest
example of how
irresponsible they've been with all this
money who people I think a lot of people
probably donate to BLM not to look
racist honestly I don't think they
actually know like the ins and outs of
the organization uh cult yeah I support
the concept that black lives do matter
and white lives do they do matter and we
should focus on uh class issues but when
I say it's an aberration I'm talking
about the corporate structure that's
taking money and buying houses yeah and
the people like this should all be
should all be transparent and it should
all be on some sort of blockchain I mean
it's a little pre it's a little early
for blockchain look at this house well
that's a nice house Conyers Georgia
house who's buying this stuff who are
these top brass anyway these people that
that's that's an awesome house right
there
she has you know this Patrice close
excellent taste in in homes it's just
absolutely impeccable look at this one
even this one's just so nice it's got a
little little backyard they made like a
little bar it's got two stories wow nice
and pack all this you know if I was
going to be running a an international
non-profit that was taking money with no
accountability that I could then use to
my own discretion I would totally buy
these exact same houses
you might even be able to write them off
maybe maybe start a business with them
rent them out and then when you get
exposed you just resign and then go get
to be rich for the rest of your life
yeah or go work for another activist you
organization that would be more than
happy to have you because you can't ever
really be canceled if you work for
people like this and I think it's
interesting that black lives matter has
they started out trying to claim that
they were all about like the police
brutality issue and then they started
bailing out like actual criminals so I
don't know if you guys remember the
story a few months ago I think it was
there was a situation in Louisville
where this Democratic activist who was
planning on running for like city
council or something his name is quintes
brown he tried to murder a mayoral
candidate oh yeah and was was locked up
for that and apparently he was upset
that this guy who was a Democrat like
wasn't left-wing enough for him BLM went
and bailed him out of jail and you had
all of these uh these Democrats like
praising this guy for how uh how great
he was as an activist like last year and
just think about Kyle Rittenhouse he
attempted to murder a politician yeah
yeah and BLM bailed him out and this is
at the exact same time that the freedom
Convoy protesters had their fun seized
by on gives and go and all of these
other Financial platforms is there any
question that he attempted to murder the
guy no no he walked into the office and
they were like how can we help you when
you pull that out why isn't that guy in
jail right now
what is he like okay so he's
Bale's another story if he's not a
Flight Risk maybe then that's another
conversation completely crazy that this
Corporation is bailing out people
that's kind of interesting yeah this
black lives matter bailed them out yes
black what happened in Illinois the
state gave 300 Grand to Black lives
matter Kamala Harris is right now uh
tweeted out a fundraiser for black lives
well not for black lives Minneapolis to
bail out the rioters who were you know
I'll be careful here the riots were very
much associated with black lives matter
but I don't want to accuse the
organization of being the same thing but
very much so the left is overt and doing
all this stuff
you know how I feel you know when we're
talking about Twitter so I was like does
it matter do we care because at this
point it's like why are we acting like
we have anything to do with those people
for all for all you know the way I see
it is
get away from the cities take care of
yourself because these lunatics are
going to go smash windows and Destroy
businesses there's no reasoning with
them there's no conversation we are
seeing some of them get charged and sent
to jail that this is you know relatively
recent thing where people are actually
getting charged expected but it's like
two or three here or there out of the
hundreds or thousands that were going
through each of these cities and
destroying them so at a certain point
it's like I just don't consider them to
be like citizens of the world of the
country that I live in you know there
there's two distinct countries and
there's no point interacting the economy
of antifa and BLM does not in any way
interact with the economy here of me so
I just ignore it it's just what's what's
the point right now oh black lives
matter ripped off all a bunch of dumb
people they're happy they got ripped off
they don't care we're complaining about
an organization we didn't donate to I'm
just like you know what man let people
be ripped off
um there was there was a point where I
wanted to to go up to people and beg
listen they're ripping you off they're
taking your money and they're buying
houses but they don't care they like it
so then what do you do yeah just well
you keep doing what you're doing and
don't get derailed by it that's for sure
uh you make better software technology
I'm not going to stop making better
Social Media Tech because there's dumb
racists out there uh I will acknowledge
them I'm not going to completely ignore
them but I'm not going to let them
deviate me from my path and you should
do the same continue on your path strong
don't I think the issue is there was a
point where there was an argument
between left and right right that we
were one country and we were going
through a you were having a bitter
period in our relationship
then at some point the you know the
other half of the relationships are
throwing bricks and fire bombs and
mortars and at that point you should be
like like when when if you're fighting
with your significant other when they
start hitting you is when you need to
leave yeah yeah so at this point it's
like you want to burn down cities the
people who want to stay there and are
fine with it I've already given my two
cents like you need to get away from
that if you don't want to okay you're
like there's a woman being battered by
your husband and you you say get away
from him and and then she won't at a
certain point you're like I've tried
what I can try if she won't leave what
am I supposed to do yeah and this is one
of the things that drives me absolutely
crazy about a lot of fellow
conservatives is that they still like
desperately want the approval of the
left whether it's like corporate media I
mean for example I'll go back to the
Trump Administration one of my biggest
complaints with them was that they were
constantly feeding Scoops and you know
leaking to the New York Times and in the
Washington Post and it's like why are
you constantly rewarding the people who
hate you no matter what you do these
people are never going to think that
you're a good person they're never going
to accept you they're never going to
think the way that you do about issues
or policy they are always going to think
that you're evil and yet constantly so
many people on the right fall into this
trap of thinking if I could just do this
one thing I could change their mind this
is part of the reason it was so
frustrating to me to watch Trump try to
get on the side of the media and he
would make fun of them and he's like oh
lion mainstream Media or whatever but
you know it at the end of the day he was
like well I really actually do care what
the New York Times says about me he kept
doing sit-down interviews with them and
why why was the Trump Administration
inviting people from CNN to go have
background briefings with Administration
officials and letting them have
exclusive quotes in in interviews and
stories it's crazy to me it was Trump's
Nostalgia why didn't Trump get on gab or
mines why don't you do a daily YouTube
video blog I mean he had everything in
front of him but he was from he's from
the 50s 1950s or whenever he was born or
he didn't have anybody in his
administration who could tell him like
Hey you need to directly connect with
people better I think it was kind of
both right I think part of it was that
he longed for the days when he was
adored by the media and was this you
know superstar that could do no wrong
and and people really glorified him and
then it was all also the staffing issues
where he did have a lot of Staff members
who were either actively undermining his
administration or just really stupid and
not very good at their jobs well
ignorant that's a good way because they
just didn't know the about the
technology they didn't know how to do it
is not necessarily stupid they might
have also been stupid I don't know this
is one of the reasons why I'm more uh
interested in a DeSantis 2024 than a
trump 2024 because DeSantis and um I
I've been told it's his wife they're
very Savvy with what's happening
culturally right and on social media
great team and so I look at that and I'm
like could you imagine how DeSantis
would handle the Press
look they're gonna smear them they're
going to try and Destroy them the same
as they did with Trump but he's just
better at it and and to your point about
like a daily YouTube video that's
something I could imagine a DeSantis
Administration actually doing not
necessarily that way but doing something
more active on social media for directly
connecting with people I think the issue
with Trump is that
politically he's in the right place for
so many Americans but he's just very old
and he was getting bad advice I wonder
if DeSantis would be a lot better with
the media because they've never liked
him whereas Trump he had this long spell
where you know he was on The Apprentice
and he was just Big and Rich and Famous
Larger than Life personality and they
they liked him they ate it up they wrote
all kinds of stuff about him even before
he was running for president I remember
Melania Trump being on the cover of some
dumb magazine when she got married to
him with her glorious dress and I was
like never again would we see this once
he got elected and that has to sting
especially for a guy with an ego like
that but I think DeSantis would get it
in the bag it will be really awesome
though if Trump wins in 2024 and then
that means he wins with the with the
help of people who vote for Biden in
2020 yeah just to prove a point yeah
just to be like hey all those people
yeah yeah Biden was bad it'd be like
Obama voters yeah you know but but real
quick that also means some of these
people are going to refuse to vote for
Trump out of the personal ego
so they might be like I can't do that I
can't have been that guy who was like
Trump is is is worse than Hitler and now
come crawling back to him I refuse I
will never admit that
you get a DeSantis and they'll be like
oh well I mean you know I was always
against Biden and DeSantis is better so
yeah the other thing that makes me
nervous about DeSantis though is that I
think there there have been a lot of
more
establishmenty and never trumpy type
people who are 100 on board with
DeSantis and that makes me a little bit
nervous because I worry that people who
were really on board with Trump
particularly the people who moved over
from the Democratic party the Obama
voters who would see that in as a bit of
a betrayal like why am I supporting the
same guy that these people support and I
wouldn't want to jump away from Trump
too quickly because I think a lot of
trump supporters did have a valid reason
for liking him in particular even over
other people who support some of the
same policies because he really was a
Trailblazer for the Republican party in
terms of a lot of those more populisty
nationalistic policies and also just
speaking the way that he did
I know a lot of people who said I've
never heard a politician talk the way
that I talk like at the shop with my
co-workers or in the locker room with my
friends things like that and that cult
of personality is I mean like it or not
really important politics downside of
that I agree I like the way he talked
like uh well I mean he said some crass
stuff but I like that he was honest and
like just off the cuff and then it's day
one he started reading speeches he'd
come on TV and he he'd be talking like
this and like that and like that's not
Trump that's not Donald Trump that's not
how he talks and I was so he just just
just
got
filed into the machine it felt like day
one you have John Bolton on staff and
like I don't I don't know why I don't
want round two not right away Bolton but
uh I think it was what Sheldon Adelson
you know told them Trump to do it and
Trump was like okay and and I I guess my
understanding is he legitimately thought
it was going to be a good idea that just
goes to show that Trump really did not
know what to expect when it came to the
school yeah he had reince priebus as his
chief of staff I would imagine if you
were going to do it and do it right for
real you'd have to have your own way of
doing it and there'll be tons of people
being like no don't do it that way no we
got to stop him and you'll be like gone
and away from them they can't even find
you because you're doing it the way you
want to do it and what I understand is
there was a plan for the second term to
root out a lot of the people who were
undermining Trump so like John mcentee
was placed in charge of personnel uh
towards the last year and he was
basically compiling like a hit list of
employees that were not loyal and needed
to get the hell out and yeah it was too
late and like Amanda millius was in the
Trump Administration she spoken about
you're changing Federal rules so that
you can fire uh non-political appointees
more easily and things like that so I
mean there's a lot of ways that this
could be done better I just hope that if
Trump were to run again that he would be
listening to the right people this time
around and make those decisions more
wisely I think we do another Trump 2024
we do another Trump uh run with 2024 and
then after Trump you get his hand yeah
it's like inevitable yeah I mean do you
think that we can handle that the
country can maintain with cult leaders
like this like a like a singular leader
over and over and over again you think
we can no no no hold together two terms
I just I fear that cult later if he only
has two terms I fear that having a
central leader is is a vulnerability
that the country can't handle but we're
having a decentralized leader Now isn't
any good either well he's a centralized
Authority he gets all the rules go
through him no no actually this what I
mean is that he's not not the head
honcho decision maker of his
administration I I disagree do you I
think this actually plays into Ian's
Point Biden is and he's insane because
his brain has deteriorated to this point
but I think look Kamala Harris she's 11
staffers have quit on her she is just
sitting there spinning in circles
confused and blabbering making no sense
there's there's no real leadership in
this administration at all I genuinely
think that there are there's a
combination of two things people
exploiting the opportunity and just
doing what they want because Biden's out
of it and people who are like what
should we do Joe and Joe's like you know
you gotta you know next World Wrestling
you know and yeah for the war crimes and
then they're like and then and then he
gets up and he goes get it done and he
walks out and they're like I don't know
what next no rest it means what do I do
I I legit think that um
you know some people believe that he's a
puppet and I'm like no if he was a
puppet there would be a plan like if
somebody was in charge
of string of events do you think it's
possible though that there's more than
one person directly underneath Biden
that is that are competing for
oh yeah decision-making ability like
hold on Clay nerd yes but that's that's
kind of my point too that they're still
beholden to Biden in a certain way and
they're they're they're you know Biden
is a central Authority and as a next
nail recent bada kaf care tune in on a
Shabbat of pressure and whatever garbage
garbled word garbage he said president
they're they're they're they're they're
unable to pull the trigger on things
without the president's approval and the
president is just basically a Walking
Corpse at this point so what that does
is when the power is centralized in
Biden and Biden can't speak words right
then
the whole system is just shaking like a
rickety bridge and on the verge of
snapping
I disagree with the idea that Trump is a
cult leader or a cult of personality
Trump is just a leader and he came out
and he said these are problems and a
bunch of Americans were like we agree no
one's dealing with those things and so
they said I'll vote for you I meant more
in the general sense of the way our
system's structured that we vote for our
hero that our our popularity contest to
put someone in supreme power is like a
cult it's like a American we call it the
government American government but it's
a cult where we choose our leader and
then we're all like ah we're all
surrounding the leaders
in congress senate the Supreme there
they're important I mean executive
doesn't have as much power as people
think but I think what's interesting
about Trump is that it was almost the
opposite of a popularity contest because
people almost voted for him because he
was unpopular like I don't think Trump
was the guy that I mean if you go back
to like the Bush election people were
like oh I'd rather have a beer with bush
than Carrie for example is that really
the case with Donald Trump like I don't
know I think a lot of people held their
nose and voted for Trump
it was kind of the opposite of a
popularity contest in that way well they
I I it was like I guess that's right I
mean it was it was almost like despite
his personality we wove over him because
we like these particular things where we
like the way you speak but name
recognition I was at the airport I was
at a airport I think I was in Texas and
I went to the lounge at the bar and
there was a woman and I asked if she
like I asked her to turn off CNN or
something and put on Fox and then she
said something about you know I can't
stand it we started talking a little bit
there was a guy sitting to my left and
then all of a sudden we were all talking
about politics she told me that she was
like look I was for Bernie so I didn't
like any of these people Biden's
terrible and I'm like here here I felt
that way in 2016 but I think Trump at
least did stuff we've never seen before
or at least in my generation the guy on
my left chimes in and he goes oh I voted
for Trump and I'll vote for him again
but I wouldn't invite him to my house
for dinner and then we all laughed and I
was like that's kind of the way I think
a lot of people felt about it you know
he was like he's a good president but
he's kind of a dick and I'm like yeah
yeah a lot of people were like we
recognize the problem of trump but and
that's why the left went so hard on the
Suburban women vote in 2020 because they
really wanted to emphasize Trump's
personality defects what I think the
Trump Administration or Camp campaign
rather did wrong in their response was
they tried to win over like white
liberal wine moms by talking about
Criminal Justice Reform and like
everything that they're doing for
opportunity zones when they should have
been talking about how like Trump could
stop the riots before they got to your
neighborhood like they they
misunderstood the solution to what the
left was telling people about Trump's
personality and he could have leveraged
that I think in a much more effective
way on the campaign Trail but and and
out so uh playing into your point Ian
about cult leaders and centralized
Authority I think if you look at one of
the most important issues in the culture
War gun rights you can see that
centralization doesn't have anything to
do it's culture
Georgia is about to sign into law
constitutional carry which will make it
the 25th state and I wanna I wanna State
for the record a correction because I
was right when I was on Joe Rogan's show
in November I said that I said I think
majority of the country is
constitutional carry and then Joe was
like no no that can't be right and I was
like yeah I'm pretty sure and then Jamie
pulled looked it up and it said 13
states and I went only 13 doesn't sound
right right that was a very old number
it was 24 I believe it was 24 at the
time 24 states have it had it it may
have been 21 at the time because in the
past four months there's been a wave but
21 better than 13. so I was wrong but
not that wrong and I want to make sure
that everybody knows this uh Georgia is
about to sign into law constitutional
carry Ronda Santos is uh is talking
about a special legislative session
which may include constitutional care
which means 26 States permit list
conceal and open carry you walk in
you're a resident some of these states
are our constitutional carry I think I
think constitutional carry applies to
non-residents as well at a certain age
limit it's like 21. that means you can
if if you're in Texas and this you know
uh and then I think
Louisiana doesn't have it but uh if you
go from Georgia to say Mississippi and
they're both constitutional care you
don't got to worry about Crossing that
border yeah this is a huge cultural
change in Victory showing the sentiment
of the American people that the federal
politicians don't matter when when
regular people vote for State Reps for
State Senators for local politicians
your state can do right
seeing all that happen shows just how
important it is that we we utilize and
pay attention to our decentralized
political system and don't stay heavily
focused on just Trump winning that is to
say good vote for Trump in 2024 if
that's what you want but make sure
you're voting in the primaries right now
2022 midterms are coming up and it's not
going to matter if people set up the
primaries because you're going to get a
whole bunch of rhinos neocons
establishment unit party garbage
but yeah the the the Constitutional
carry thing has me super excited yeah
yeah me too I mean I'm a gun owner
myself
um well actually I recently lost them on
a boating accident it was very tragic
but you know I love guns um grew up with
guns and like I'm a huge proponent of
maybe having classes in school where
students can learn gun safety I think
that would go a long way towards making
people feel more comfortable with gun
culture if they didn't grow up with it
did you did you see it I think it was
like Alaska or something yeah you were
doing Airsoft training I think that is
awesome I mean what no no no it's
terrible why those kids should be
outside with 22s okay all right you got
me they shouldn't be using Airsoft in a
gym they should be outside with River 10
22s and they should be getting proper
instruction it'd be fantastic I mean I
think that uh you would see a a huge
reduction in things like accidental gun
deaths or I don't know like some of
these other statistics that the left
likes to throw out to make people afraid
of guns if you just Ray raise people to
understand that they are a tool that
needs to be treated with very specific
safety regulations in the way that you
you behave with a gun and they're not
toys to be played with and they're not
anything to be afraid of let's have a
gun debate we have this story from the
Daily Mail gun wielding Texas man who
shot dead his partner's ex-husband
during Furious child custody Rao will
not be charged after shooting his rule
to be in self-defense this is a very
very interesting story
so you can see here these two guys are
getting at it one guy's got a gun I
think it's a it's a um I can't remember
which kind of gun it is but it's a nine
millimeter a long gun of some sort
so I'll just give you the quick rundown
and then we're gonna have this debate
because you know we were talking about a
bit about a bit before the show
so this dude is told you pick up your
son from your ex-wife at 3 15. he shows
up his ex-wife says no he says where is
my son she says I wanted to stay with
him longer so I'm not gonna be giving
him to you and he says you know in fact
he basically is like I'm here because
the court says 3 15 he is mine I come
here after 15 and then he goes I'm gonna
drag you all you and Marie and so-and-so
to court right when he says this his
ex-wife's boyfriend comes out with the
gun
and comes on the porch and tells him to
get out the dad gets up in his face
doesn't use his arms and starts saying
oh are you going to shoot me or
something like that the dude with the
gun fires one in the ground then they
they tussle spin around the dad pushes
the homeowner a few feet off his porch
and the homeowner his wife's
ex-boyfriend or his wife's current
boyfriend his ex-wife's boyfriend
immediately raises the rifle and goes
pop pop towards his own house hitting
the dad twice killing him instantly I
believe it was instant
now uh the court is saying he is not
going to be charged with a crime this
one's tough because on the letter of the
law I'm torn on this one was he acting
in self-defense did he have a right to
shoot and kill this dad who was coming
to get his son there's two ways I look
at it the first is if the court tells me
be here and get your son you have to do
it it's custody like you have no you
can't just ditch your kid and I show up
and they're like we're not giving the
kid up or telling you where he is and
then a dude walks out with a gun I'm
gonna be like you've kidnapped my child
and now you're threatened me with a
weapon I'm here under a court order
does that guy have a right to come out
with a gun
on that alone I'm like no and then not
only not only did he shoot and kill the
dad he pointed he shot he shot and
killed the dad towards his own house
that's one of the one of the rules of
gun safety know what is beyond your
target he could have shot his own
daughter because his daughter was
filming on the inside I couldn't really
tell when we watched the video maybe we
can watch it again I don't know were you
planning on playing it I don't know if
we can't yeah it's pretty brutal you
have a dude but the daughters are in the
House filming out the window okay when
he aims at him and fires his I can't
tell if he's pointed at the house or
like pointed sideways alongside the
house the guy was on the porch so I'm
pretty sure it was at the house and then
the other problem was that he shot into
the ground to sort of escalate the
situation and that's another No-No you
don't fire warning shots right like
because you don't know what's where
you're pointing I think they knew each
other the big dude was abusive and the
little guy I was a big dude abusive I
just have this is the feeling I'm
getting from this the big guy was
notably abusive that's why they weren't
together and the little guy they knew
each other and they hated each other
because he went right at his face when
he came out with the gun they got right
in each other's face so this is the
problem I have with it
if the the Assumption of uh this guy's
name is William Carruth who who shot and
killed Chad Reed
if you're in your house and you hear
fighting outside and you don't know
what's going on you have a right to keep
and bear arms into our property I agree
I might get my gun as well people are
screaming I'll be like I don't know
what's going on but there might be
something bad happening you walk out
with your gun next thing you know a guy
gets up in your face that's screaming at
you your first reaction is to fire into
the ground as like you can call an
escalation but you have the option to
shoot the guy just got up in your face
maybe he just panicked and said I think
it's stupid to shoot in the ground mind
you and then the guy grabs you you both
spin he pushes you back now he separated
you from your home
he could go in and harm your daughters
so you say pop pop
from that perspective I'm like I get it
we don't know what this guy knew but the
problem is man the the Chad Reed guy was
there legally to pick up his kid and and
it didn't even get there was not enough
time for him to even call the cops
apparently his new wife was already
calling the police about about the
argument when the art when the yelling
happened and all the dad said was I'm
taking you to court like not even a
threat of violence and the dude walks
out with a gun that this is the
challenge here because if this dude
William Carruth knew why the dad was
there you know and what was going on and
came out with his gun then I'd say
charge him but we can't assume he did
know and he gets back I had no idea I
heard yelling and then it's like gun
rights if people are fighting on your
property you got to write to defendant
and like you said and we don't know the
history of of these two guys I mean it's
possible that they've gotten into it
before he knows that this guy could
potentially come into the house and harm
his own children or or be looking for
this kid I mean we really don't know the
situation I'm also sympathetic to the
idea that if your son is being withheld
from you and you have a right to be with
your son then parental Instinct kind of
kicks in and like people will do
anything to save and help their children
if they feel like their children are
being parentally kidnapped so I
understand that impulse at a certain
point though you have to be smart enough
to think
if I get myself involved in this
situation if I'm trying to grab this
guy's gun whatever
am I better off trying to be the better
person in Retreat and potentially save
my life and get the court or the police
involved as opposed to trying to
start this fight that you're not going
to win because you don't also have a
weapon I mean it's this is it's a
difficult situation I don't really know
how like who is I meant right here I
mean maybe they both were wrong in
different ways but it's it's tough
because like do you send a guy to jail
because he pulled a gun out his own
property because a guy was yelling and
then a guy got in his face but then I'm
also thinking about if the court orders
someone to be there
and you come out like imagine if this
guy was a cop who was instructed to be
there by for law enforcement purposes
and you walk out with your gun and the
cop rushes you I guess it's different my
issue is just like this dude is trying
to get his child and when the wife is
saying no and he's like my kid's been
kidnapped a dude then comes out with a
gun and at that point I'm sure the dad's
like you've kidnapped my child and are
threatening me with a rifle with a long
gun like yo I'm surprised all he did was
get in his face well he also chest
bumped him which is aggregated
and then he touches the gun too he
touches the hand that's on the gun which
basically is that dual possession at
this point like the Ahmad Arbury case
you know if you if you put your hand on
the weapon not that's basically you're
just telling me you're gonna try and
take it out of my hands but not when
they separate and the dude goes pop up
the the challenge is do you really blame
a dad
for getting in the face of a guy who
pulled up who walked out with a gun when
his son's missing we gotta talk about
what's legal and what's right that's the
thing like morally I don't think that he
was
necessarily wrong but legally I don't
know that even if somebody has your kid
if you're allowed to go into somebody
else's home or try to grab that like I
don't know what the what the legal
situation is definitely not if someone
ever comes out on their front porch with
a rifle and tells you to get off their
property get up their property you go to
the truck and you call the police I mean
you're you're asking for a bad situation
at this point not to victim blame but I
think that's the best we can do to be
honest yeah that he should have
immediately backed up backed away and
said I'm getting the cops and the cops
would have come and he would have won
the fight exactly the cops would have
been like you are illegally withholding
a child you can't come out here with
that weapon go back in your house and
guess what he would have probably gotten
more custody of the kid if he had let
this play out because they would have
been accused of endangering the child as
well
yeah that Split Second of the dad
walking up to do with a gun you see him
snap when the guy comes out with the gun
he just goes right in his face like he
wants to fight that guy man yeah because
if you're if his kid is it's his son
like he doesn't even care about the kid
anymore he just wants to hurt the guy
this was like almost inevitable to me
the way that these guys were so quick to
go after each well let's get to the dark
part the dark part is the mom has the
kids living with the dude who killed
their dad that's nuts apparently the
kids were like this is yours this is
almost like these kids are probably
gonna hear this show someday man at this
point it's like I'm sorry guys I mean
I've
apparently the kids are like really
upset as they should I gotta be honest
if it were me when I was a kid I would
have ran away
yeah no joke I'm not gonna I there's no
way I'd live with the dude who you know
killed my dad well now we I don't know
enough about the conversation because
that guy might have been really abusive
but you said the kids I mean it's still
their dad no they're apparently saying
like it's your fault you know wow
it's a crazy story this is America so
traumatic and
they're aware that Kyle Carruth shot and
killed their father in front of their
mother stepbrother and myself
a judge not a denied the petition for
custody so this is um this is the the uh
the the dead father's new wife she was
trying to get custody and they were like
no you're not a blood relative so the
kids have to live with the dude who
killed their dad there's so much with
our
two because like that the default would
be you have to go to a blood relative is
obviously super problematic when you
have family members that are not fit to
raise children and I think it's really
unfortunate that you can't assign to
like a family friend or a distant
relative or something like that in a
situation like this where clearly these
kids are living in a traumatic
potentially abusive situation and yet
you can't separate them for whatever
reason it's another reason why I think
uh for example like a lot of the impulse
to always give children custody of the
children or majority custody to the
mothers not
always the best policy either
so there's a lot that needs to be
reformed in that system maybe if they
had gotten this right from the beginning
this issue wouldn't have Arisen to begin
with
man I suppose the challenge is the
moment that
Chad Reed was on the porch with access
to the house and Carruth was off the
porch with no access to the house that's
where it becomes justification because
now he's in between Carruth and his
daughters yeah
it might have been Chad Reed's daughters
I don't know
yeah it might have been his kids I'm not
entirely sure
yeah I guess there's some context we'll
need to we would need to pull up
I I think it I think it was his it might
have been his kids in there I'm not
entirely sure if it was
um if it was Chad's daughters then that
would have made this guy with a gun more
callous about pointing it toward the
house I think that actually kind of
makes sense which I would think would
then be an argument for not ever leaving
those kids in his custody ever these
poor kids oh I don't know where they end
up so sad
yeah I think the kids inside the house
were Chad Reed's kids
yeah oh my gosh I'm not sure though that
that's that's important yeah a little
bit but he was only there to pick up his
son so again I'm not entirely sure it's
been a while we covered this when this
we talked about it when the story first
first broke but uh I wonder if people
are pointing it out no I don't know well
you guys comment you guys Super Chat and
then we'll get to it when we talk about
Super Chat so we can you know maybe
correct the record if we got if we if we
mix something up
crazy stuff man I'm curious yeah this
was a crazy philosophical conundrum I
gotta say how about how about we uh do
you guys want to waste time talking no
that's not yeah personally Madonna or we
can talk about something what's Madonna
up to yeah oh gosh all right let's talk
about what I'm talking about Madonna hot
minute I think this is one of those
stories that we can get in trouble for
talking about it's uh
man this is this is more of a like a pop
culture kind of thing but I also think I
just want to talk about it she's got a
lot of face work done oh yeah but yeah a
little bit so take a look at this
Madonna's bizarre Tick Tock video raises
eyebrows as fans grow concerned over the
Stars unsettling appearance what has she
done to herself
this is such a weird video too I saw it
first it does look like she got
ridiculous plastic surgery and it makes
her look really bad uh but there's a
couple of things I wanted to point out
and I think there's places like cultural
issues for one the obsession with
relevance on social media
Clearly Now like this is like what did
she posted on Tick Tock yeah and
everyone's sharing it but I wonder if
this is actually just the front-facing
camera making her look yeah it looks
like a fisheye lens of some sort I don't
think so because she's posted other
bathtub photos and videos the bathtub
thing on her Instagram and Tick Tock
that make it pretty clear that this is
some pretty heavy work being done and
she like had her butt done too and it's
one of those really obviously fake
situations where you don't even know how
they sit down on it gosh uncomfortable
so here look at this video
you can see it
it's just creepy
oh man it's so cringe it's so creepy
what is going on so here's here's what I
want to talk about this because it's
it's it's it just it is kind of relaxing
to talk about the identity of of this
pop culture stuff but I also think what
people don't realize celebrities get
plastic surgery and then they look
really good and no one says anything but
then when they age the weird Scar Tissue
doesn't age the same way a regular face
would so they start to look really
really weird as they get older I used to
take care of old ladies and sometimes
they'd get boob jobs
and this these things would stay where
they were implanted and the rest of the
lady would sag and I was like why did
you do this to yourself it was horrible
and you could just see them oh my gosh
it's horrible but anyway yeah I want to
advise people not to get plastic surgery
unless you have to like for medical
reason or something don't do it don't
hurt me why does anyone do it I really
don't get it I mean the only situation I
could see that's semi-justifiable is if
you're like a TV personality and you get
like a little bit of Botox to even
outlines in the forehead I mean
something really minor but why
vanity is a real thing and and
unfortunately when you have people on
social media for all of their lives I
think it's more difficult now than ever
to age gracefully and if people are
really nasty about appearances on the
internet I mean my teeth are Jagged like
a jigsaw puzzle I wear the same clothes
every day I wear beanie all the time I
got no hair or whatever I'm not going to
get surgery I'm not going to get the you
know I got uh I got uh crowns I think
yeah that was because my my molar
cracked I had a root canal when I was
little and then this one yes
reconstructive surgery is fine I mean
you want to use plastic surgery for
reconstructive burn surgery stuff like
that that's what it's for I mean that's
that's a phenomenal advancement in human
medicine but don't rip up your face well
and did you guys hear about this story
with Bella Hadid the supermodel who got
a nose job when she was 14 years old
like her face wasn't even done growing
into itself yet and apparently her
parents signed off on this cosmetic
procedure and now of course she regrets
it she's like you know I had this really
interesting ancestral nose and I think I
would have grown into it and now I'm
forever living with the knowledge that I
modified myself in a way that I'm not
happy with when I was 14. they're gonna
get uh I was hearing stories about like
young girls wanting to get plastic
surgery to look like filters and that
like older women are getting plastic
surgery to look like the filters make
them on Instagram
yo there there is a there's a malignancy
is it coming from the internet that's
making people like that's what I was
saying before about like social media
Tick Tock whatever making people do this
it's coming through the internet but
it's not from the Internet it's coming
from people individuals are are either
inadvertently perpetuating a six cycle
probably they want to look like cartoon
characters a lot of this like the whole
idea of for the furry thing like I think
I'm a you know fuzzy animal no they
don't think they're animals I think
they're cartoons I think beautiful you
can be is who you really are you don't
need to mash up your face or your body
or any of that stuff it's healthy too
because it makes you more beautiful true
that yeah this is a crazy thing to me
too I've never really understood why
everybody wants to be somebody else
not everybody well I I mean that
figuratively I know what you mean
because even I play role-playing games I
like to fantasize about being a hero in
a Strange Land you know and sometimes it
makes me a better performer just
thinking those things like living up
fantasy realities I mean like of course
we all we play games sometimes there is
escapism that I'm not talking about that
I'm saying how like people are like they
look in the mirror and they're like I
need to cut this up and re-structure it
I I want to be something different it's
like why I don't understand why you're
not happy with just being you I think
that this especially applies to women I
don't know if you agree with me on this
100 I find it to be so much simpler to
just be yourself put a little bit of
makeup on paint the bar and my dad used
to say but I think in Madonna's case
it's because she's getting older and she
knows it and I think it's terrifying to
her so she's like really going out well
especially in like the world of Pop
stardom yeah right you almost have an
age limit on how long you're allowed to
be relevant in the industry and there's
a lot of pressure from music Executives
to look a certain way uh I mean like
gone is the the world of these amazing
like 70s singer-songwriters that could
look however but as long as they
delivered a good music product they
would be really successful now there's
really this pop star culture where you
kind of have to look and dress a certain
way in order to be popular in the music
industry and I think that's really
unfortunate and then there's the
question of just social media's
amplification of people's insecurities I
mean growing up like as a young teen
girl
I felt like we all had body image issues
and worried about our appearance I can't
imagine how much more difficult that
would have been if I was on Instagram
all day looking at these influencers who
all look exactly the same yet none of
them are real they all have the plastic
surgery or filters or all of these other
body modification tools to their
disposal editing software Photoshop
things like that when you're fed that
feedback loop constantly that's really
hard for young women and I I think if
you're a parent like you have to be
thinking about limiting your kids access
to social media and their phones as much
as possible no social media none I feel
I don't I don't want them to have a
phone nothing like you get a brick iPod
and that's it yeah and this is funny too
because I I several years ago I was like
I got my niece a cell phone so that she
could make you know learn apps and do
all this stuff and be tech savvy and
then I remember being like you know her
dad took it away saying I don't want her
to have this and I was like why would
you do that now after a couple years I'm
like
that's good idea yeah take a look at
this photo right here oh these guys oh
no
look at the so these are the two famous
brothers or whatever twins
bogdanov twins yeah did one of them die
recently they think they both yeah they
both did why would they want to look
like that so they were TV stars right so
we took us out ready for this oh gosh
that's them when they were younger
before work
right they still look weird starting to
look like everything else but like
that's the problem with work it makes
you look like everything else but I'm
wondering if vague and boring no no I'm
wondering if they got the work when they
were young and this is what happens when
you age with all that no that's more
work more work more work definitely yeah
they went overboard 100 did they think
they looked good yeah no I think it's
kind of like they never did I think
social or plastic surgery is kind of
addictive in the way that tattoos are to
some people yeah as well that's how it
is if you think you look bad no amount
of plastic surgery is going to change
that so these people do it and then they
still think they look and then they do
it and they still think it's like comes
from within this makes me think a little
bit of gender reassignment yes because
the problem is not in your physical body
it is 100 inside your head and no amount
of changing your body
is going to fix what's going on in your
mind and this is what people who
de-transition say they're like nobody
dealt with the problem that was you know
my thing
unless food is like no amount of plastic
surgery is going to fix your mind but
the food can fix your body and your mind
well look if you look in the mirror and
it's I think plastic surgery cosmetic
surgery and any kind of body
modification surgery any kind be it
trans species like some people do or
transgender whatever I think you've got
a disconnect between your your
perception your body or whatever and as
you're as you're mentioning that's the
issue like the body dysmorphia yeah so
my my issue here is
there's literally nothing you can do
unless we develop like nanotech cellular
cellular reprogramming or something and
then you go into like a stasis chamber
that changes your body or something we
just do not have the technology to
actually give you something that
represents what you see in you know or
why nor should we I mean I mean I don't
think well I mean if if what if we
literally develop technology that you
can like actually I don't know
physically change your body literally
legitimately in the future somehow then
I'd be like okay whatever I say okay
whatever to a lot look if these people
want to do this I got no problem with it
I'm just saying right now the technology
doesn't does not exist to make you look
the way you want to look right so right
now our best course of action is to
teach people that it's going to be hard
but you're going to have to change the
way that you think and you can use
cognitive behavioral therapy there are a
lot of different things that you can do
I don't know most people don't want to
go on to antidepressants I completely
understand that but right now we have
the power to change how you view the
world and even though I know it's hard
and every day might be a struggle people
who deal with addictions have this and
they overcome it and this is something
that they really get a grip on and every
single day is a struggle I still manage
to do it so I think if we can change
people's minds now we should make that a
higher priority then so let me ask this
question though for uh because you're
saying they shouldn't like people
shouldn't modify their bodies is that a
fair assessment uh I mean in cases that
where they have like a medical problem I
think that's different for for aesthetic
reasons no I don't think they should
like what if what if we get to the point
technologically
where you can actually take a 10 year
old kid and they walk inside a chamber
and then they actually completely change
genders like literally biologically 100
percent no you don't think they should
do it no absolutely not I mean and I'm
Catholic so maybe this has like
something to do with it but I'm very
resistant to
altering
human nature in the way that we
experience the world I think that gets
to really dangerous places what if they
were 18.
and they walked in and like like a genie
snap boom it was they were the opposite
sex and I still think that's bad no yeah
I'm not about that at all it's an
interesting question because you know as
we're thinking about plastic Surge and
all that stuff I'm like is the issue
permanent body damage that these kids
are going to be many of them sterilized
or or you know is that the is that the
issue and then if there was a way that
the kid actually changed like to me I
don't support gender transitions
generally because I don't think they
address the underlying issue which is
the insecurity and the body dysmorphia
and then for kids it's worse because
it's life-changing and they're not
obviously of of age to consent to that
type of yo it's going to be real crazy
when we're in the metaverse you're gonna
have a kid born in the metaverse and
they're going to be like oh hey Mom I'm
trans and then they like click a button
and their Avatar just changes but we're
at the point when we're at the point
where your brain is plugged in and their
their digital bodies are
indistinguishable from base reality then
people are going to be walking around
like dragons and care carrots and
there's gonna be a rabbit you're gonna
sit down in your office and there's
gonna be like a big rabbit and he's
going to be like hello I'm like John
you're both I just don't see any way how
that's not bad for like a truth Centric
Society right like we should want people
to try to seek truth this will be crazy
if we if we if we get to the point where
we we primarily exist in the metaverse
you could be born into a digital reality
where your brain's Plugged In Like The
Matrix choose an avatar for yourself
that's say like a giant carrot and then
one day when the metaverse breaks down
you get ejected from it you'll be like
oh what am I like I'm not a carrot
anymore you'd freak out you know I
actually took some heat last week I know
imagine that on Twitter again but I was
talking about this press release I got
from this company that is actually
partnering with the metaverse to create
a narcos experience in the metaverse so
you basically get to be a drug lord and
like run this cartel or whatever like
that but for me it's a different
experience when you feel like you're in
it right like that's Westworld level
stuff
and I play video games like I'm
definitely not a person who says ban
video games because they lead to
violence or anything like that but to me
the metaverse and there's been
preliminary studies that have talked
about the effects of virtual reality on
the brain and apparently when you're
doing these things in the metaverse OR
in virtual reality your brain actually
stores them or implants them as if they
were real memories and so if you're
going in and doing violent stuff in the
metaverse how does that fundamentally
alter someone's perception of the world
and what negative effects could that
have for people's entire lives after
that if you think that you killed
somebody or you think that you were
running drugs like I don't see how that
can lead anywhere good for society
I think there's we often talk about the
negative things about the metaverse but
there's positive things too you safety
trainings you know without real risk of
harm for a lot of a lot of issues
training firefighters trying police
officers it's going to be teaching
people are going to go in there with
legalized psychedelics it's going to be
so crazy Society is about to split into
it's about to fractalize into a bunch of
different ways of being I'm nuts dude
different laws different societies
different
religions and relationships different
languages are going to start springing
up you know they're gonna like in North
Korea they'll take thousands of citizens
plug them into the metaverse and just
never tell them just to like see what
happens oh dude I've been working on a
script by the way I'll tell you about it
later but but think about this for
reminding me so you have in your country
people who do physical labor for
producing food and resources and
machines and then you have intellectual
and Abstract labor which is like writing
songs or developing code software things
like that
you could take all of your intellectual
property development people and put them
in the metaverse and just seal them off
and then they can do the same they can
they can do the work digitally with
their minds plugged into a computer and
then everyone else can just you know
till the fields and make food or
whatever yeah what will happen is their
mind will be working so fast but if
their body gets Disturbed it'll slow
down their thought process and they'll
be like no we can't have that do not
disturb his body keep it sealed off so
his brain can work at Peak capacity
imagine imagine right now all of a
sudden you're sitting you know you're
sitting wherever you're sitting you're
watching the show you feel this pulling
sensation in the back of your head and
then all of a sudden it feels like you
are actually being pulled out of your
body and then there's a flash of light
and you're standing in a field and
you're a duck you'd freak out right yeah
you'd be like what is this like where
are my hands why am I a duck that's
what's going to be like for people who
grow up in the metaverse and choose to
be a duck and then when they get pulled
out and they're a human they're gonna be
like I have hands what uh my their
identity would be totally fractured and
separated from their bodies you know I
wanted to cap off this um this plastic
surgery conversation because I was
trying to bend my face like I'd pull the
bones open slowly over time so like I'll
spend an hour and just hold it in place
and I think it actually slowly moves
over time like clay I can't tell if it's
real or not well that's why they tell
women when you're putting like
moisturizer on your face you're supposed
to go like this instead of like this
yeah more like this the bones are
growing and moving you can slowly over
time move the like hold pull the jaw
outward if you want a bigger jaw and
stuff like that just takes a lot of time
yeah those ladies they put the rings on
their neck and they make their necks
yeah
it's crazy all right let's talk let's
let's go to the Super chats my friends
if you have not already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it and
head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
around 11 p.m or so just around there
and we will get to your super chats
everyone in chat is saying yo WTF lol
Ian's crazy give it a try yourself
before you go knock it till you try it
all right let's read some of this
Malcolm a key says previous Super Chat
con oh what is this previous Super Chat
other accounts whom have met the same
criteria criteria for such a ban remain
untouched Putin Ayatollah Taliban just
in Trudeau I don't think we got your
first super I saw one disappear and I'm
frustrated well uh for those that are
listening if you put if you super chat
before the show goes live YouTube erases
it yeah don't do that
be patient GG player says huh Amber kind
of looks like she could be Lydia's
sister
oh I like that look at us I love it
that's very nice yeah I'll take that all
right the lukewarm gamer says Rumble
should put money into non-political
culture content to bring people who
aren't political to the platform if
Rumble signed a deal with Hollow live
for example it would damage YouTube more
than getting any political YouTuber
yeah that's the one thing I've I've been
saying to all these guys who are doing
alternative stuff is like everybody just
keeps going politics and I'm like why
well and also the people who do
entertainment-minded stuff are not very
good at it like people on the right need
to be developing talented filmmakers and
artists and people who can create
content that's entertaining that doesn't
suck and doesn't have all of these like
really shoehorned political messages in
it I think Gaming's where it's at you
get Gamers on Rumble because I mean look
at ROBLOX for 40 billion yeah yeah
yep definitely all right Derek Brown
says if anyone can do what everyone else
thinks is impossible to Elon Musk he
always has a plan yeah I like how Elon
was warning us about the art of the AI
and then he's like neuralink and some
people are there's a meme where they're
like Elon Musk warns about the dangers
of artificial intelligence then
literally tries to plug your brain into
a computer
and but people don't realize he said the
same thing I'm pretty sure Elon said the
only solution to the threat of AI is to
integrate with it I'm pretty sure that
was his point yeah that's the idea yeah
yeah so then hey I can't destroy you if
you are yeah the AI you guys ever see
that have you seen that new Terminator
movie where uh the Terminator is John
Connor whatever and he has like the
weird robot Powers no no I heard it was
terrible well maybe
um but I was thinking about it because
in that movie
so this time the Terminator is John
Connor and the Terminators are like we
realized the only way to defeat Humanity
was to merge with them and they're like
oh no and I'm kind of like
okay so you're still a person but you
have crazy robot superpowers I don't I
don't understand why that's a bad thing
I mean I guess if you don't want to have
crazy robot superpowers because he could
like he had like nano power like Nano
robots and he could like you know change
shape and do crazy stuff like is that is
that bad I don't think so depends who
you ask I guess I think you don't like
it it's true I don't you nailed that
yeah for the same reasons I don't like
the other stuff that we talked about
yeah that's a scary thought about
what's happening with metaverse stuff
it's going to separate your mind from
your body
and then when they ask you what you lost
you won't be able to remember
yeah that's
all right America float says it feels
like false hope from musk since
BlackRock and Vanguard own nearly just
as much each maybe a pump and dump One
Last Ride for Twitter stock or maybe
phase one
maybe maybe a bunch of other
billionaires and Wealthy individuals
will start buying shares of Twitter and
pushing back BlackRock only owns half of
what musk has yeah BlackRock only owns
like 4.6 but that means uh Black Rock
and Vanguard together have what yeah
well there you go yeah that's maybe what
it is is he's going to try and get a
majority stock I don't I don't know it's
not worth it dude don't throw billions
at that junk but free the software code
all right Jacob Andrew Hester says Tim
driving to your neck of the woods for uh
for work from Alabama due to bad flight
delays any good steak or seafood
restaurants you recommend thanks for
everything y'all do we same people
appreciate you mean same people
um if you are driving on 3 40
heading uh just past Harpers Ferry
you'll eventually come across a gas
station
that says live seafood that's what it
says right it says live seafood I don't
know apparently it's a gas station with
seafood and everyone out here is like it
is the best
because it's like small country knows
what they're doing Seafood interesting
well Amber's a native I am really good
recommendations for seafood too I guess
it depends on where exactly this guy's
traveling through like is he going to DC
or
uh you can take 15 20 minutes out of his
day to go hit up the the Harpers Ferry
Virginia Maryland area there's there's
the Bavarian in really good and I think
it's in Shepherdstown right you're
familiar with them and then uh this
other restaurant we've been to that's
really amazing is called Dutch's
Daughter oh yeah I love that recipe have
you been there before many times are you
a fan it's overrated you think it's
overrated yeah like I I thought it was
fine I think it's really overpriced I
mean compared to like five ten years ago
their crab cakes used to be some of the
best in Maryland and they've really gone
downhill well I haven't had the crab
cakes but I had uh a steak did you get
the filet Oscar yes that's the move it
was good yeah that is pretty good and
the and the and the crab imperial yes
yeah that's good stuff see see like it's
overrated but well it might mean you're
paying what like 40 50 bucks it is
overpriced yeah it was expensive I mean
you could just like go to DC and go to
Morton's for that and get like a cowboy
rib eye DC rib eye this was a filet
mignon where's the best seafood in see
uh in DC you probably should go to the
wharf and go to one of like the old
family owned restaurants on there there
are a couple of them like fish fish
market vibes
but the best crab cake that I've had in
recent years is that Jimmy's Seafood
which Lily and I were talking about
earlier
yeah and they got into a war with Peta a
few years ago and put up all these
Billboards around Baltimore just like oh
I remember that basically bragging about
the fact that they were live steaming
crabs and Peter got really upset about
it but they do make a really damn good
crab cake like lump meat
size of a softball really good stuff how
do you feel about stem cell meat
I just I just think she doesn't like it
the filet Oscar at Dutch's Daughter was
one of the best filet mignon steaks I've
ever had really I mean the the
preparation was well maybe they've
improved since the last time I was there
it's been a year maybe we just have
different tastes could be I've been I
have better taste it could be I don't
know we've gone to a bunch of
steakhouses uh in our day uh Alex Jones
brought us out to I think we went to was
it capital group I didn't go I missed
out yeah I think it was like me and Luke
and uh really good but when I went to
judge's daughter and I got the filet
Oscar it's like a filet mignon with like
crab on it oh it's just cooked yeah and
I will say generally speaking corporate
steakhouses are not the best place to go
if you want a really good steak because
it's so standardized across all these
different restaurants that sort of
inevitably there's going to be a decline
in quality at some point do you like the
Bavarian Inn in Shepherdstown yeah
they're really good too that's so much
fun it's like a Bavarian in complex it's
so cool yeah all right let's read some
more Super chats I think we're hungry
yeah lizards well someone asked said I'm
like um we've been looking to find like
the good food because we periodically
will do like company outings where
everyone goes out yeah what kind of uh
Mexican food do you guys like oh me de
gallo
it's it's oh this is amazing so there's
a there's two there's a Mexican
restaurant out here it's called me
degoyato and it is amazing I love
getting chicken fajitas it's just so
perfect like Tex-Mex is up your alley
yeah yeah but umato means like my slit
throat like my to cut a man it means
like to cut a man's throat that's right
I remember and so you know I remember
asking the server like hey like what
does this mean and he's like oh it means
to cut someone's throat and we were like
wow that's awesome he was like oh it's
the name of the town the owner's from
and then I was like I don't know if
that's better yeah you're from a town
and then I was like well if there was a
town called like Cutthroat in New Mexico
I wouldn't think twice I'd be like oh
yeah you know yeah that's true but yeah
that's what I like
there's a couple of good places in the
DC area
um Anita's gets really good reviews uh I
like to go to Uncle Julio's which has
like three or four locations in the area
but despite being a chain actually has
fantastic fajitas we'll just don't get
their queso their queso sucks what's
that famous sandwich place
oh there's so many
the one that Richie went to you remember
oh I'd have to find the text I don't
recall was it like an Italian sub that
he got or something no I got a roast
beef roast beef and he was like it was
like some from famous DC series no uh
no no we'll just read we'll just read
more Super Chat all right Ian went to
the bathroom so I'm going to read this
one now before he gets back lizard says
you're rolling lots of 20s today Ian
good job he will never hear your
compliment no we'll make sure the time
all right Noah says
love the show guys I just want to use my
first Super Chat to let you know that
Louisiana has also introduced their own
version of the parental rights and
education bill look up Louisiana House
Bill 837 amazing glad to hear it the
catch is on this is the craziest thing
someone on Facebook posted why why are
we mad at Disney now
and I wrote the left is upset that
Disney did not sign on to the protests
against the parental rights and
education bill they feel that the bill
is discriminates against the lgbtqia
community by preventing teachers from
having discussions about these these
issues with kids eight you know grades
kindergarten to third grade the right is
upset with Disney for now having signed
on to the protest because they feel that
the the bill is preventing teachers from
sex having sexualized conversations with
young children and I thought it was like
a very milk toast like this is the best
of my understanding and they all just
got mad and they were like no bigots and
I'm like okay whatever man I don't know
uh say Mima type says did you all see
Stephen Crowder own Steven monacelli in
his latest change my mind I did I
thoroughly enjoyed it that's the guy who
canceled me yeah yeah you then you will
he did get owned it was awesome oh you
did see it oh I found it very enjoyable
I was I was watching like this
all right let's grab some uh what do we
got
Charles Bloomer says that Steven guy is
the same guy that tried to outsmart
Crowder on the last change in my mind
episode and and what was he thinking
it's just so crazy to me that you're
like I didn't do any research but I'm
gonna sit down with a guy who built a
whole show about this one topic that's a
thing is like the media people who write
for these mainstream Outlets don't have
to know anything because they never held
accountable when they get things wrong
and a lot of them are just like super
narcissistic arrogant people who become
journalists not because they care about
information or truth or whatever because
either they want to promote a certain
cause or they want to promote themselves
I mean that's just kind of how it is now
yep all right that's what we got here
John freuch says if the Earth is
orbiting the Sun at 93 Million Miles
Away how is the North Star always North
P.S I am not a flat earther and the and
the Google answer is laughable off the
top of my head I would assume it's
because the North Star is so far away
that it's like you know Parallax
scrolling you ever see that in video
games you know what Parallax scrolling
is yeah Parallax is when the far other
way it is the slower it looks like it's
moving in the sky yeah vanishing point
perspective so in a video game where
you're playing like a 2d side scroller
there will be multiple layers to the
background that move at different Paces
the further away it is the slower it
goes because that's kind of how it tries
to imitate real life well that's kind of
why the North Star is always pointing
North because
it's so ridiculously far away that the
amount of movement we experience in our
days and lifetime
doesn't change it also electric Universe
check out the electric universe theory
it's pretty cool
Zach uh helke says I would take a bullet
to the spleen for Amber athe's right to
make a joke we all needed to subscribe
to The Spectator to make sure she can
keep making them
that's really nice thank you should I
give them my discount code or is that
like you have one I do oh yeah of course
oh perfect yeah if you use Amber all
caps you get 10 off a spectator
subscription so is this a campaign based
off of them firing you or you've always
had it we've always had oh yeah okay I'm
not I'm opportunistic but not that
opportunistic oh yeah I mean maybe we
should figure something like that out
with you know with timcast.com all right
A lot of people are commenting that
Steve guy was on crowder it wouldn't be
it wouldn't surprise me to believe he
was the cause of this yup yup
all right Mike Sullivan says Tim great
guest hire her uh well she already works
for The Spectator just gave out her
discount code so she's a great
John L says Amber I'm sure James O'Keefe
would have a much easier time digging if
you sat down and talked with him it
doesn't have to be public the only
problem now is like could you imagine if
a silhouette of Ambridge appeared on
Project Veritas I wonder who that is
yeah gosh I can't imagine uh I mean
maybe off the record I I just I'm not I
can't say anything now because I don't
want to get sued but
we'll see all right Brian Duchesne says
Tim I was a big fan of your show when I
first found it thank you very much
that's all I said moving on oh no oh is
that Alex said he says but after
watching it for a few months Ian and
others have proven this show is full of
amateurs by the way that includes you
well who are these others you're talking
about
many people are saying I don't know what
amateurs mean but um if if if you mean
that like
we started it with a table with um vinyl
glued to Big foam boards yeah and then a
year later we stuck a bunch of office
desks to each other and bolt them
together with like black paneling on the
wall and now we're to the point where
we're at in an actual studio with
cameras on the wall but we're still just
using like um what are we using stream
deck instead of try casters obs I mean
yeah uh if you go to a studio like
Crowders they have tricasters you know
they have these big things these crazy
Rigs and we just have like
you know cameras mounted to the walls
it's better though you know it's getting
there we're building a new studio so
definitely getting better we're going up
but you know I I got to be honest you
know if we're amateurs it's fine I guess
the company's working and growing so
well you gotta start somewhere if you
look at the professional media industry
they talk off of like prompters and
stuff that's not the aim with this this
is like a casual chill show I don't know
it's Tim's show it's not my show but
it's it's it's better it's the show it's
better like I've done a lot of cable
news and trying to distill your talking
point into a 30 second sound bite sucks
yeah it really does with no opportunity
to clarify because they'll be like we
are running out of time and they play
the music or whatever yeah so here it's
like oh did you mean this oh yeah what I
meant to say was you can actually you
know flesh out your ideas
all right Howard says the number one
rule in Fight Club Fight Club number one
rule in parallel communities no fight
laugh at them drive them crazy refers to
mass formation psychosis they hate it
when you laugh love and laugh never
engage just laugh live your parallel
life and laugh all right Howard I
appreciate it that was hard to
understand but I think what he's saying
is ignore the haters and just laugh and
keep on going and they'll get really
angry about it I respect it yeah that's
right
Integrity media says Tim I wonder if
people reported Twitter with each
State's elections division for not
reporting the like kind contributions to
Dems they favor when Banning the GOP
opponent failing to report his
election's crime and the New York Post
yep yeah
people should
pursue it however they can pursue it I
suppose
I don't know or we just
keep building the parallel systems daily
wire they're doing absolutely incredible
with their culture and Dan bongino has
invested a lot in these parallel systems
Dave Rubin as well with locals we've had
our work we've had our criticisms of
locals but it's still it's a net
positive across the board something
compete with patreon I like it it's
Rumble and it's all about servers and
decentralized servers locals should be
off stripe and should be on Parallel
economy
yeah agreed done 100
parallel economy you guys should check
it out
it's it's new but um it's it's good
stuff
hopefully it ends up working out all
right Chuck Hawk says keep up the good
work Tim and crew support independent
country music download no vaccinations
and other Outlaw tracks free on band
camp tonight I like vaccination it's
it's not it's something different it
means totally yeah all right Howard says
antifa money comes through the Ukraine
laundry service along with traffic child
trafficking drugs bio Labs so Elites ATM
is messed up right now and there are
let's say let's just use the word
euphemism child abusers the US oligarchs
Clinton Obama Mitt Romney Biden pal and
cam so many others and CIA Bush and Tifa
money is not coming the elites are
worried Howard I completely disagree I
don't think they need Ukraine for that
and there's uh I think the issue was
more Epstein if you're if you're talking
about corruption from powerful Elites
and money funneling and stuff Epstein is
the first place I'd look Epstein Island
whatever it is they were doing and the
Panama papers Ukraine is
I think Ukraine's actually a bit more
simple the US was trying to gain
influence to control the flow of energy
into Europe which screws with with
Russia because they that's like one of
their principal exports so Joe Biden
knowing this is the official position of
the United States sentencing his son so
that the sun can wet the whistle of the
big guy for 10 share bank accounts it's
actually a bit more simple and all of
that's actually corroborated yeah check
out kolamoisky if you want to look at
the Ukrainian ties to this stuff to the
corruption stuff but I'd love to you
know know anything about Epstein Island
oh yeah and how nice that the judge just
denied a retrial for Elaine Maxwell and
she's never had to name the conspirators
the people who actually paid for the
services that they were providing it's
like arresting a drug dealer because the
cops saw him like hold a bag of drugs
and raise it up and then like hand it to
nobody and it falls on the ground and
they're like get him and they're like
you were dealing drugs to no one but
still
clearly there has to be another party
involved yeah like at the very least a
cop right yeah you know like he was
selling drugs to a cop and then you're
like yo he was giving it to an
undercover officer no Maxwell it's just
like you were trafficking kids to no one
how do you prove she did it without
confirming that she didn't
it's because they're protecting whoever
she did it with yep
yep man I
oh man
all right K comco says we need a
Churchill speech for a call to action to
State re uh two states re-term limits
fire and term limit every admin Branch
person put an end once and for all to
Putin Etc make a graceful exit in four
years
term limits are our tough question tough
question because
um some people have just said you can
vote for who you want to vote for it
doesn't matter how long they're in there
and if you have term limits what ends up
happening is oligarchs will just rotate
out politicians and it's actually fairly
easier for him to do so yep he was
pointing out term limits for the
administrative State as well sounded
like oh yeah the staffers you shouldn't
be allowed to be a staffer for more than
a certain amount of years
all right Dennis McGriff says Ian by
your logic does that make every
president a cult leader yeah I guess so
well all right then Mike Sullivan says
Lydia it's a nine millimeter Carbine oh
oh yeah
pine tree Squad says Tim great example
of adjacent states with permitless
constitutional carry is m e and hnvt can
drive from Maine all the way through
Vermont without being required to show
your papers
isn't that funny to make you show your
papers
yeah man I knew I felt the story before
a guy was driving from California to New
York and got pulled over in Illinois and
they were like you're going to jail for
four years because he had guns now he's
an Illinois resident congratulations
all right now back to that story about
the dead in Texas we got some super
chats shotgun Rebel says Dad had no
authority to enforce the order has to
let police and law handle it best
interest of the child that way uh and
that is what Texas does in custody
issues I agree with that yeah the Dad
should have immediately just backed off
yeah it's tough man I understand why he
was mad though but he would have won and
he would have won substantially if he
backed off yeah imagine the cops showing
up and he's like they're withholding my
kid and the guy came up with a gun the
cops would be like whoa then when he
goes to court your honor they wouldn't
give the child to me as I was following
your instructions and then the guy comes
out on his porch with a gun the judge
would be alike that's not safe for these
kids yeah instead he ends up losing his
life it's tough man
Taylor cook says you missed it he tried
to take the gun on the porch the
potential warning shot was the only real
red flag here I'm not sure the first
shot wasn't an ND into the ground the
father was trespassing
it's tough yup Josh Branson says itself
but the father should have left called
the police and called it a kidnapping so
much as I hate it too
um the BF defended himself if the kid
was in like Plain Sight and was in
danger that's another story then the guy
has to fight for the life of the child
but if he's not in plain danger yeah
you're right he also didn't even know
for sure if the kid was there I believe
because didn't the the mom say we're not
telling you where he is
voro says Tim you missed the part where
he says you better shoot or I'm gonna
take that gun and F and murder you or
something like that granted he never
tried to actually take the gun but still
there was a verbal threat yeah yep I
think that's important to point out
absolutely
man
some other people are pushing back
though let's see
Ryan says Texas custody law says if if
the primary conservator doesn't release
a child as per the custody agreement the
police will not intervene as it's a
civil matter not criminal you must file
a complaint
oh now it gets even more crazy because
what's the dad's supposed to do then
just let her kidnap the kid yikes
seriously JK says JK says Tim the guy
was already outside then went back into
the house and came back out he was
already part of the situation
oh wow it sounds very complicated yeah
it is
YouTuber says there are two videos of
the Texas incident one from the
perspective of a woman in the house and
another from the woman in the car watch
both and you'll see it was not
self-defense it was murder if the dude
walked inside and grabbed a gun and
walked out that's a different question
because then he would know the context
of the situation right and he and and he
knew that the dad wasn't threatening
them with violence so for him to go and
grab a gun when the dad was just like
I'll see you in court and that at that
point I would actually argue the
boyfriend should have called the police
he should have went in the house called
the cops and said he's getting
belligerent we just want someone to come
and deal with it instead he went out
with a gun
that's tough yeah but then around
someone else's property and just the act
of getting a gun isn't an escalation
necessarily I mean we learned this in
the writtenhouse self-defense case him
being out there with a firearm was not a
provocation for people to attack him and
try to take his weapon
yeah all right Channel Zero says hey Tim
you guys still coming up to pork fest in
June in New Hampshire my friend and I
run a conspiracy theory debating podcast
Channel Zero Rumble Spotify emailed
pitches would love to join IRL when here
we are planning it however we tried in
January to get modifications to the
mobile studio for independent power so
solar panels batteries that can run
everything and that completely fell
through and our money is being jammed up
so we need to find someone who can do RV
modification and it's been really
annoying
we're going to Nashville in a week yeah
that's easy because the daily wire is
going to run cables to our mobile studio
in order to be able to you know do the
show from our new mobile Studio it's a
better setup with uh with no issues and
then hopefully by the time we get to
June we'll have sorted out the the
batteries and everything so that we can
run the show but it'll it's it's it's
tough maybe we'll figure it out well
we're also going to need satellite so I
don't know WordPress is tough because
you know internet infrastructure Luke
was mentioning if we got like um
starlink or something but I'm not
entirely confident I'm not entire
entirely confident
Jacob Perez in reference to this plastic
surgery segment says gorgeous Squidward
meme
yeah have you guys ever watch
um Teen Titans Go at all no have you
seen the one where Robin takes off his
mask no so it's it's like
so Teen Titans I I mean I I knock I I
watched so uh anyway I used to watch the
original Teen Titans ago it's just like
a kid's show but I did see the one
episode I've seen a handful of them
where
Robin always wears a mask and he never
takes it off so the other Teen Titans
are like take off the mask show us what
you look like and he's like no I can't
and then finally like they keep trying
to take it off whenever they take it off
there's another mask underneath finally
he agrees to take it off and he has this
ridiculous looking face like the
Squidward Meme and then they're all like
shocked because they think he's insanely
beautiful or something I don't know it's
funny
all right Angie says uh Angie says
Rakata law said that the police would
not have helped the man that was shot on
the porch they would have told him to
take it up with the courts which is what
he said he was going to do
sad story man the bipolar God of Science
Fiction says is it violently offensive
that I've been tripping balls for the
last five hours laughing at Madonna's
video maybe maybe people will try to
cancel me but those same people are
probably already trolling her in the
comments over there should serve as a
cautionary Tale
is it violently offensive not to me I
don't care it's hilarious yeah it's not
possible for you to be offensive it's
only really possible for me to be
offended by what you do after the
receiver to decide if if they're
offended or not you can try and offend
but you can't decide if it's offensive
or not Ryan Brown says I am starting to
think PayPal is deliberately attacking
timcast.com with their more frequent
issues keeping subscribers from
accessing member content I won't put the
blame on PayPal there is an issue that
affected US based on our look we were
called amateurs earlier Fair Point when
we launched the website it was just like
a very basic WordPress because I was
like I don't wanna I don't want to be on
patreon it's other platforms we'll make
our own thing and there was um this
simple issue that basically resulted in
something happening after one year for
members where it disconnects to your
account from timcast.com and then we
need to reconnect it for some reason I
don't know but we are setting up a new
more resilient system that once is fully
fully operational then you know I'll
have a more exciting announcement
I think people can probably already
figure out what I'm talking about but
let's just say we're upgrading to a new
provider and I don't blame PayPal for it
but we do want to not we we do want to
diversify who we use for memberships if
you're having issues send an email to
members at timcast.com and we'll we'll
we'll get you sorted to the best of our
abilities it I just want to be honest
with everybody I I really do apologize
because we have so many members and
we're trying to grow and we need to add
more people so it gets it gets tough to
answer all the emails we get from
everybody just for everything
all right
what is that dork tanian parental
kidnapping is a felony in Texas carouth
was assisting in the crime and would
fall under Texas felony murder rule if
charged wow
that's crazy
all right here we go someone's got a
science answer for us Michael Conaway
says the North Star Polaris is almost
directly above the Earth's axis it also
States the north it also States the
north Celestial pole is restless and
over 26 000 years will describe a 47
degree Arc through the sky we'll descend
we'll describe interesting hmm
interesting
part-time Doge says Stu Peters just
swatted I don't know who Stu Peters is
it is I'm curious now
R.L Corley says hey hi Tim are you gonna
go see Sonic the Hedgehog two you betcha
I went saw morbius boy was that bad
what's more beautiful things more BS is
a character from Spider-Man who is like
he's Dr Michael morbius and he's dying
so he does an experimental thing with
bats and then becomes a vampire
I'm on the Jim Carrey train right now
after Harry or didn't isn't Jim Carrey
and Sonic yeah yeah oh yeah mother Grace
was Jared Leto no no I've just moved on
from morbius after that I'm into Sonic 2
now Jim Carrey man when I saw him
respond to the Will Smith slap on stage
or the Will Smith attack that was the
best the best thing he's done in years
Jim Carrey man his art sucks yeah a
little bit he had like a uh something
chain like like a what would you call it
like a spiritual awakening or like a
midlife crisis or something in 2010
this is important being funny after that
yeah but it's way more interesting many
such cases yeah Alex Jones was right 420
says Tim have you seen Amazon is
creating a Fallout TV show please no
damn it's gonna be so broken and weird I
hope they use ammo as currency and not
bottle caps they already kind of screwed
up Witcher so yeah yeah that's Netflix
yeah I heard Wheel of Time was was woke
people were mad
I don't know though I don't I don't know
anything about Wheel of Time no the
Assassin's Creed movie was really bad
too and the Uncharted movie looks
terrible it's like yeah morbius was bad
very rarely six is our video games
turned into other forms of yeah because
you can't play them you gotta watch
that's like you know you know that
backwards guys and these campaigns take
like what 10 to 30 hours then you try to
condense it into a two-hour movie what I
don't understand about morbius or I'm
sorry I mean Sony movies when they try
to do Marvel characters is why they
don't just look at what a Marvel movie
is and then just copy them
like these movies they all feel very
much like it's 2003
and they're just really bad remember
Daredevil with Ben Affleck I didn't see
it oh come on I saw Spider-Man one with
Toby Maguire and then I saw Iron Man one
and I was like I cannot watch it anymore
this trash it's just trash all right Ian
if you haven't already smash that like
button right now subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you really like it we are going to
record our members only segment which
will be up at timcast.com post it we'll
post it around 11 or so p.m so make sure
you sign up there if you want to support
our work you can subscribe make sure to
subscribe to this channel make sure you
follow us at timcastiro basically
everywhere except Tick Tock because we
got banned and you can follow me at
timcast basically everywhere else Amber
do you want to shout anything out I
would love to you can follow me at Amber
underscore Athey on Twitter and I
already shared the discount code for
spectator but it's Amber for 10 off a
subscription just go to the
spectatorworld.com did you shout out
your Twitter too
all right and I also wanted just to
clarify I know those movies sucked I'm
not just gonna complain I'm actually
making good art as a result I've been
working on scripts we're also putting
together social media technology so you
can ideally have subscribers that can
follow you without a middleman taking a
percent of your stuff so actively
solving some of these problems that I'm
finding in society and I will see you
later
you guys may follow me on Twitter at
sour patchlets and on minds.com as well
I also have sourpatchlets.me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys